y right good morning everybody Welcome
to overiew and scrutiny committee on
Friday the 1st of December which also
happens to be councelor Keith's birthday
so many happy returns to councel
kiy looking young as ever looking as
young as ever so well done thank you um
right first item on the agenda uh how
apologies please
yes morning chair we have apologies from
councelor lwood and councelor hener
sarapin Brilliant thank you very
much next item is the usual disclosure
of Interest any disclosures of interest
can Ral yes I thought you might be can R
please why did you think that Al in q
no actually I don't think I need to
disclose an interest but I will when the
item comes up no I want to disclose an
interest on the cabinet papers when we
discuss the seal spend because the youth
Collective which is due to have a large
amount of money donated granted to them
is one of my Charities as mayor of
statford upon aen and I think it's very
important that you should know that and
I perhaps should not take part I take
advice I should not take part in the
discussion okay um the general topic of
the I think in your specific instance if
you're if they want of your Char that's
perhaps wise um it's probably worth
saying at this point we have discussed
this as a team and we're going to
propose to give a general dispensation
to allow the cabinet members to discuss
it um otherwise we won't have the
ability to have a debate and we'll do
the same for counselors when it comes to
S of full is it is something good to
full counselor is it just cabinet the S
spend I
can't but yeah we're going to give a
generally we're going to give a
dispensation for our members to speak so
long as the interest are declared
because otherwise everybody's got some
form of interest and we can't have a
debate so that the plan is I would
rather not say anything about that
particular uh youth uh organization okay
excellent yeah no that's that's fine I'm
I'm always on the air on the side of
caution I much rather do about later and
if you want me to declare an interest as
being the only counselor in the room
that has any dealings with Ellen Q I'm
quite happy to but I am not going to
stop talking when it comes to that item
oh no because I have much to say no we
didn't expect you Cel R so no but uh we
rather you uh yeah I'm say again it's
openly open and I think it's fair and
transparent minutes of the previous
meeting was on the 3rd of
November four weeks ago doesn't time fly
when you're having fun uh any comments
on those are you happy that I can sign
them at a later
date agreed thank you Chairman's brief
just again wish councelor keithy happy
birthday that's in the minutes again
enjoy the MP oh well that's
there uh upake on the task and finish
groups councelor Wally hoggins do you
want to give us a brief update on that
for us
please uh so at our last meeting we had
two two um two two two groups came to
speak to we we met with the private
house sector housing manager and um his
overview of what what we get involved in
with the district council with regard to
um social housing was very interesting I
think that the figure that came to that
came out was that 40% of their time is
spent dealing with um in a in a last
resort capacity with social housing of
which that brings is quite um there's
quite a lot to think about under under
that um that's probably not for this
briefing not here but we'll be from the
recommendations eventually from the
overview and scrutiny the findings from
that
um it was really
um he looks you know they look at the
nature of the the age of the buildings
the longevity um that that kind of thing
and also the challenges um but he did
say that they are the people of The Last
Resort really for those are just
frustrated Beyond frustration and mainly
that has to be with some of the larger
um housing stock you know owners within
within that
um there were concerns there that um you
know everybody seems to be quite active
in resolving down from mold issues but
again it is
um there's twings and roundabouts in
what they are dealing with and what
they're not not dealing with um what we
did what we did suggest was that um the
the Council requests monthly reports
from um orbit to the to the and other
housing associations to the overview and
scrutiny committee or to all counselors
so that members are aware of the level
of monitoring and what's going on with
the social housing stock in their areas
um because that helps with transparency
and it helps for those in need of social
housing to make informed judgments about
where they're going to accept houses Etc
because they mustn't feel they're forced
to take a particular house from an
association housing Association that's
being badly run and uh you know so that
was that was interesting um we're also
requested a full list of map for the
district showing um which property
managers for certain housing
associations cover which areas um can I
know that we're going to come on to more
of this
later we also had a very humbling um
visit from the citizens advice Bureau
who you now all know are based within
within this within this building um the
citizens ADV advice uh Bureau
um all counsil has got a cost of living
briefing uh which was led by the
citizens advice um and uh the number of
social housing issues has grown
disproportionately to the issues of
housing in general um and um they
they're going to provide further details
on the issues and figures reported to us
then which um I I say humbling because
it's the breadth and scope of what
they're actually dealing with and the
amount of visitors
that that they're getting um and I think
we need to be really mindful of that
this piece of work that we are engaged
in doing affects a huge proportion of
some of our most vulnerable um residents
as well and that is why I take this role
really seriously of the holding to
account and to making the social housing
providers within statford and Aven um
assisting in the process of making them
the very best for our residents and I
won't I won't rest until you know we
have a good good plan of action with
that uh the the citizens advice
confirmed that um the the seems to be
some sort of skewed the perceived level
of of deprivation uh in the district is
actually contradicted by the the the
figures that they have um
um the cycles of activity that they were
very busy in the summer usually the
summer is um is sort of a lull area but
this this year they haven't seen that
it's been
um a Non-Stop kind of um you know Open
Door really
um they also talked about the referrals
that they make to auk and mind um I also
asked if it would be possible for the
Citizen's advice to give us an idea of
those in our district that are seeking
advice from citizens advice because
certainly for those of us that haven't
perceived um wards that perhaps are um
in a better we perceive as being a
better Financial uh situation it would
be very very useful to have those and
not withstanding that we're also aware
as District councilors of funds are
available just within our wards that
that may be able to help with issues
that they're facing it comes down to
fundamental sometimes that they're
having to buy new appliances for people
moving into social housing so for
example um all cookers and all fridges
Etc are removed from a premises no
matter how old they are because for
health and safety reasons so people are
moving into properties without any
carpets and without basic appliances you
know you rarely move into a new built
home now without the being of and fitted
so so that that that's something that we
that we do need to bear in mind so yeah
we've got two more meetings um scheduled
for the 26th and 23rd of February um
with a final uh report to overview and
scrutiny coming uh to before before
Easter and that's on the back of the
surveys that will be coming out as well
I'm sorry about the length of this um
briefing uh chair but I do feel it's
important because of the gravitus of of
what we were told uh at our our last
meeting and again my grateful thanks go
to Howard for his um incredible ability
to to Corral people into coming to speak
to us thank you very much indeed it's a
um it's a real skill you have there
thank you did you say Coral or blackmail
I couldn't couldn't hear that thanks
thank you no that's was very helpful can
while hogins no as we need to dispens
time on that and you know you were quite
brief so no it's not a problem compared
to lots of meetings I've been into that
was a quite a brief update thank you and
very informative so thank you very much
next item is should be the minutes from
the climate change panel yes uh meeting
held on the
S oh we oh yeah well done you spotted my
deliberate mistake there how good job
somebody was a away listen come on
committee I was disappointed you didn't
point out that didn't talk about the
task and finish on the budget uh you
know then I was doing this deliberate
mate just to make sure you were still
awake and you let me down it's eating
all those M po wasn't it so I blown
cancel Keith people this one right then
um we now need to discuss the uh
makeup of the climate uh the budget uh
working group Tusk and finish that we we
have each year um last year catch Curtis
and I were on it uh and counc Curtis
will still be on it but in with a
different hat on
sove got some form of continuity which
is which is quite good so thank you for
that um we really need to decide um
membership of this group um it is
important um and as you can see the
criteria it's public interest can I see
realist realistically influence the
issue yes we can uh is it relevant to
all large parts of the district yes of
course and does the issue avoid
duplicating work yes so there there's
lots of good reasons why we should be
doing this um but really yeah um as you
can see the meetings are lik to be held
on the 10th 17th and
24th of January
20234 so yeah I think that's 2024 isn't
it yeah it says 20234 I spotted
deliberate mistake there just making
sure somebody was reading the papers and
I saw that bit so um councelor R
please uh yes um does this budget task
and fish group have to be made up of
people solely from the on uh committee
because I actually believe it should be
opened up wider thank
you so um there's no terms of reference
just to limit the um memberships
strictly to the OC but in by in the past
it's been advised you know that it's
largely drawn from the scrutiny
committee so we only need really three
members um we've got councilor lwood and
councelor passingham have already put
their names forward so just one
Committee Member um additionally uh is
all that we need
really uh I'm going to be honest I think
that it puts a huge strain on on you
know we we are not exactly a full group
here um but it does take a a huge strain
on ESS and I do think some of these
groups should be open up to outside um
at County all task and finish groups are
open up to
everyone um and and certainly at town as
well and I just think in this case we
can't keep using you know we're all busy
people and having to be you know come
from one group only makes it very
difficult
councelor rise
please um not to um comment at all on
what Kate has just said sorry councilor
Ralph as the chair of audit and
standards and a member of this committee
I would like to put my name forward so
that whether that makes any difference
to the the numbers um and
composition yes so that that's three
members that have put their names
forward now um there's there's no strict
limit so if anyone else did want to
volunteer as well then that would be
fine but um otherwise we do have enough
people now c h then caner Johnson please
yeah I mean really as the leader of the
major opposition group I'm going to need
to be on that overview of scrutiny
committee but also I would also like to
nominate Trevor Harvey to be on that um
group as
well you can thank you yeah caner
Johnson I'd wish to volunteer as
well tell this is amazing you know we
got concerns about the the workload on
the members of ourc and all of a sudden
we can't get enough people volun to stop
volunteering so obviously I think this
is obviously a wide subject I think I
was being slightly F there I do
apologize but taking catch the Ro's
point
about workload I think we have got to
consider that and I think we perhaps
have it on our next meeting to discuss
these items in general in terms of
workload in terms of how we invite
people Etc and say and how we discuss
this because it is a valid concern and
and people do have other things outside
the district council to do as well so I
think that's a valid point we need to
discuss that I think further but at the
moment I'm I'm happy in fact really
happy could say exatic that we've got so
many people volunteering to give cancer
Curtis a hard time I mean to question
catch the Curtis do you want to come in
David please thank you very much ch um
just checking that the it is a minimum
of three to be cored but there is just a
there is no maximum and I do think it's
I'm leaving myself open to question here
but or scrutiny but I think it's very
important that we do have political
balance on that task and finish group as
well so thank you councelor w hoggins
so can we just have a recap of who who
we've got
now so the full list of names that's
been put forward um Malcolm littlewood
Dave passingham Mike rice uh Sarah
willly hoggins Trevor Harvey and David
Johnston so that's a total of seven
people six
sorry um councel W hogins has obviously
nominated coun Harvey from who's not on
this group would you have somebody in
mind then please because i' be more than
happy to agree to that as well in terms
of fairness no I don't but but in terms
of
fairness it it's got to be it's got to
go both ways I don't that's what I just
said that's what I just said to you
um we either say no to councelor Harvey
or we ask our group but we won't know
until you know there's not we need to
ask can I yeah right if we're going to
go to semantics on this Trevor Harvey is
the expert on our group with regards to
this all right he was the portfolio
holder last time around I think actually
for the task and finish group that that
we've got uh ahead here and the budget
that we're facing I think actually
Trevor will be a really useful person to
have on the task and finish group all
right so if it comes to it I am
perfectly happy and content to let
Trevor Harvey take my place on that task
and finish group that is is not you
know because I trust Trevor's judgment
implicitly and I think it will be a
poorer group if Trevor Harvey is not on
it frankly because of his experience and
and I think that you know if we have to
come down to that you know this that and
the other actually at the end of the day
this is really important and yeah
political balance is is important but
actually what's really important is that
we get actual people in the room and on
that task and finish group that can
understand the uh budgets to do with the
council all right it comes down to the
statement I made last week about
throwing the baby out with the bath
water right we that's so that's my
that's the option that I'm giving you
here but I I would prefer to be on it
with Trevor but if it comes down to it
Trevor is far superior to me with
looking at this than that because that's
his skill set and that's his experience
thank you chair I'm bring in Mr Perks KN
come in and then cancel off yeah um just
in the obviously it's not for me to
deter who goes on your group but um I
think it was just worth sort of pointing
out the reminding ourselves the
different groups that look at the budget
um what's important is that we got a
robust budget for the council going
forward the function of the overview and
scrutiny committee is to scrutinize that
budget to make sure it's accurate and
deliverable um that sits to one side to
any sort of political aspirations there
will be a sort of an alternative budget
from either of the opposition groups can
come forward which sort of sits slightly
to the side of the osc process which is
literally to scre ize the budget to make
sure that we haven't missed anything to
make sure it's deliverable and accurate
so we have got two slightly different
functions here um whether that affects
the political makeup of the group or not
I I think it's more important that we
get the skills on the group than the
politics and the osc side of it and then
the political side is dealt with through
a separate process might be
useful oh we'll bring you in a minute
cancel off I'm say I've not got a
problem with if we invite
um if the the groups want to invite one
member from their group who's not a
member of OC to join the task and finish
group and in in our conserva dis case it
be councel Harvey and then if it came
it's a later date um from the libd group
a nomination I'm more than happy that
would be fair and reasonable um Kate you
want to come back in there I was just
going to say that uh I'm happy to ask
the group if uh the liberal Democrat
group if uh one more nomination could
come forward for this group for the
Budget Group okay it
fair thank you very much chair yes um
just following on from from Tony Tony
perk's point the point that the
rationale for this task and finish group
is to ensure that the budget is sound
and I would certainly uh agree with the
points councelor W hoggins has made on
that task and finish group we need need
um as much expertise as possible and I
certainly would welcome councelor Harvey
on that on that group but it's not in my
it's probably not up to me to say that
but I I certainly would we we want the
people with the best skills as well as
political balance on that group I get
your point counc Curtis you're not
actually nominating but you're you're
you're valuing somebody's input which is
which is a subtle difference so I I I
tell that so I think we've got a way
forwarding Planet eventually we've got
quite a few people people nominated
we've got uh one uh nominated from
outside the group already who's should
be attending once we caral him using
herod's words to to get him into into
the group and then we'll just have one
nomination from the liberal Democrat
group that will be notified to Mr
Allison at the earliest opportunity but
definitely prior before the 10th of
January
right finally got there in the
sorry I put the microphone out I do
apologize um have anybody got any
comments on the minutes I would like to
make some um but I would prefer other
members to speak before I do before I
come in cancel passing please yeah
um there was um a minute on on that from
that committee that the um that the
website for climate change was being
updated well I had a look at it this
morning and it looks as if it's half
finished in some places and there's not
an awful lot of information on it so I
wondered if anything else had happened I
I know it was it's not a long time in
terms of
getting websites updated but
um yeah I I can take that away and sort
of check that out with the staff who are
involved if that would be helpful I
haven't got this morning
thanks councel keithy
please thank you Jo thank you chair um
yeah I had a question in respect of the
um transport plan for the
district um there's a there's a comment
on page 12 that the leader had had a
conversation with the war County Council
transport planning
team and I note on our work plan uh page
36 item
15 that we're
overdue something from borkshire County
Council transport
planning um
there is a new local transport plan to
emerge I'm I'm also aware that some
specific work has been done in respect
of sustainable travel
options for the
area and some traffic modeling these
reports have been delayed and I'm just a
little concerned that we're not getting
as much
transparency about the
Regional transport plan and these
studies that that
perhaps we should have yeah and and I
would like to request that um we see
some of this uh this draft information
in respect of the uh regionalized
transport plan for the district because
I haven't seen anything yet personally
thank you say would make sense and the
other thing I'd like you know
potentially see how it links in with the
South Roy local plant and how obviously
you one of the key drivers sorry that's
no pun intended on this occasion when we
talk about transport that's the int ones
are the better ones AR they um uh I
can't think of another word instead of
key drivers now um one of the key
drivers in sou work local plan is
infrastructure and obviously we've got
to get the traffic infrastructure um
passenger transport infrastructure in
place to make sure you know we get the
best uh South workshire local plant so
be be good to see what implications
there are for that as well but Mr P you
just would you think what were your
thoughts about an update I know we've
got lots of Partners and obviously the
the County Council was the highways
Authority uh and the lead in terms of
Transport but there's obviously various
linkages in terms of the planning
process so what your local plan
sustainability
um do you think we need a paper in terms
of where we we can clarify what's going
on so we can join up the dots and what's
happening and because the time scale
seem to be slipping and we seem to have
I will bring in
SE uh yes I suppose this is one of the
issues with the two-tier Authority model
where the war County Council are the the
highways Authority um and we need to
work with them you're right um having a
a transport strategy that matches the
South local plan is key we are sort of
working with them to deliver that um
ltp4 has come out it doesn't it's not a
particularly strapford Centric sort of
report and I believe the meeting the
leader there was a suggestion that there
might be a a regional supplement for
that it would
[Music]
be I think it would need to come from
the County Council to be meaningful to
you we could we as officers could give
you a an sort of summary of where we are
which might inform what you wanted to
look at that might be something that
would be a first step in the process and
as you I think councelor keithly
identified there in your work program
for somebody that you want to sort of
come in and get them to sort of talk you
and present their plans so maybe if we
could sort of give you
a some potential lines of inquiry to
sort of help you sort of form a brief
for them would that be useful yeah they
do seem to be I'll bring you back in
stud there just seem to be some
ambiguity or lack of clarity or
especially when the time Scouts Etc or
who's responsible so I think if we got
you know if we really know where we're
starting from um in terms of who's
responsible for this when I like to be
what the implications are for sa
workship plan different planning things
I'm I'm happy that we do that CC KY then
councelor off yeah thanks chair
um uh deputy chief executive made some
some some good comment points there the
the difficulty we have is the two-tier
system with the county responsible for
uh the roads highways and other
infrastructure yet the district
responsible for planning um and and what
we hear more and more is that uh the two
are not very joined up and some are
chasing ahead and the others are lagging
behind I think it's um a a response in
respect of um transport planning um
development uh is overdue and I would
like to see something coming forward to
our forward work plan so that we can we
can see what progress is being made
thank you well if if it would be helpful
I can provide you with a a summary of
what we know in the position so far that
might sort of allow you to refine what
it is that you want and we could work
out who who we should invite whether
it's the portfolio whether it's an
officer relating to it um then Mr
Allison I'm sure will Corral somebody
into joining you to meet the
committee C off
please uh the transport plan has been
produced um and at the moment it's um
not for
distribution um so I believe uh so uh
myself as a county counselor has not
been able to see it um and I don't know
whether uh counselor Crump as a county
counc has seen it but certainly our
group has not seen it I believe that
there are some some anomalies in it and
I think those anomalies have gone back
to um uh where it came from for more
clarification
but there is a transport plan produced
um and it's not for um consumption at
the
moment Council passing on please I I'm
just looking at the County Council
website and it says it
the the um fourth local transport plan
was adopted in
July so when when it says adopted surely
that means it's been voted on by the
County
Council what's the date on that um July
2023 well we'll see clarification I
think it might be the principles about
it might have gone to C it um but we we
we'll talk about no this is a sorry to
overlook over here this is just a draft
this is a draft it's not gone through ah
right just to be an overview of what it
is right the draft's adopted right
okay we we'll get some clarification on
it anyway but again I think that's just
highlighted
that we need to be more concise and have
some idea what's going on so I think I
think if Mr Perks comes back with what
he said he was going to do um and uh
we'll be happy with that so I think we
got some actions um again any other
points on the climate change meeting
panel meeting before I come
in um yeah there's one one
thing I'm all in favor of um there I've
got some concerns about this climate
change um the UK climate emergency UK um
assessing in in overall terms I think
this is something you should be doing
again some form of benchmarking Etc and
I felt that again we need some
comparisons of local districts and
bories in in terms of how we're doing
Etc um I think there was an issue in
there where we need to make sure we do
the right to reply and we do it robustly
because again there's lots of
assumptions in in there um that weren't
clear and the one point that I picked up
and raised was
that um we scored really low um yet
we've got one of the best recycling
rights in the country not the county in
the country and we perform
poorly sorry we was been shown is
performing um is only 28% in this area
and that slightly concerned me so I
think if we're going to do this we need
to spend resources and I know we've new
got a new climate change officer um
Ellie I'm not sure that's the the the
right name the climate change officer
but apologies if I haven't Ellena Warren
is a full title but Alie is what's a a
job climate change project manager Brant
so I got it somewhere there no mess
right um but I think that we need to
make sure the climate change project
officer uh manager make sure we if we
are going to respond we respond as
robustly as possible learn the lessons
that have coming out of this and make
sure that again we've got the
information on the website that Council
passing on um highlighted and we've got
the resources to do this so it's a fine
balance in making sure we've got all
information out which I think we should
have and then we've got time to respond
to the um these scorecards because if
they're doing that they can't be doing
some of the schemes that we want to do
in terms of
sustainability in in as part of the
action points on page 11 and page 12 so
it's a balance but yeah let's make sure
you know it's my accountant head coming
out that if we're going to Benchmark
make sure we use the right data um and
we're comparing apples with apples not
apples with pairs so I'm I'm and you
know and if we there are anomalies such
as in in terms of recycling um I think
we need to look at that as well because
it's all meaningless
otherwise right so I've had my
rant um hopefully we we can agree those
minutes uh and then we'll move on
hopefully now to item seven on the
agenda where we've got London and
quadrant Housing Association and even I
can't get these names wrong we' got the
head of strategic house Angela James and
being my middle name is James if I can't
get that name right and Carl you got two
lovely names both beginning both four
letters as well so it's nice and easy
see even I can't get those wrong so
thank you very much for turning up and
uh have you two please okay um thank you
very much for inviting us today we
really appreciate sorry can you hear me
okay yeah um we just wanted to say um
thank you uh for having us here at this
meeting because um although we're a
large organization and I'm hearing some
of the information back from the task
and finish and the surveys that you've
asked us we do appreciate the work that
we're doing in this area and I hope we
can demonstrate some of the things that
are happening our development growth
here um and that we see you as an
important part of the business and you
know we want to build those
relationships so we're really you know
grateful for this invitation
today um is right if you yeah sorry
thank you um so lmq housing are a very
large organization um we were formed in
1963 and we currently house around
250,000 people in more than 105,000
homes which I know when I started
working there I've been there about
nearly two years it is quite daunting um
but we've got the infrastructure set up
to do that and we mainly work across
London the southeast and Northwest of
England um we merged um with um last
year with a Housing Association in
Trafford housing in Manchester so we
have got some properties there um and
we're more than just a a registered
charitable Housing Association but I
think in the last year and the way in
the housing world really we are taking
stock of you know what we've already got
as housing um and how much more we
develop but then the challenges in
London in particular and in the
Southeast and I'm sure in this area is
providing affordable housing so we still
need to ensure that with the financial
strength we continue to build but part
of the last couple of years really has
been listening back to really what
residents are saying um the pressures
and looking at things like the
challenges of investment in in our
current stock um and also since post
grandl you know building safety
regulations and making sure that we're
managing that so we have got um an
ambitious program across our whole stock
that we will be doing a 15-year Major
Works investment program worth5 billion
and that will be working on all our
current stock NOW the stock we've got in
in this area obviously is new build but
we want to make sure that we learn from
those lessons and that we continue to
sort of invest in our stock and and work
with residents on what we are
developing so we've got a development
pipeline that we started two years ago
so we haven't been with straford upon
aen very long in the last 2 years
comparison to other organizations but we
have currently got 295 homes in this
area and we've still got a development
pipeline planned in rugby warshire and
bedfordshire so we have sort of um
seeing this as a priority area that
we're going to continue to develop in
because we have been engaging with other
local authorities and saying at the
moment we're going to put on hold some
of the development we're doing so that
we focus on the areas that we've already
committed to and we're going to make
sure that we finish those complete those
and continue to see what ways we can uh
provide affordable housing Fiona
Fletcher Smith is our chief executive
who you might have seen on inside
housing and other information she is the
chair of the g15 which which um is the
London um Forum of all the main housing
associations and part of her job is
really as well seeing how we can
influence policy um um legislation
working with the government as well on
on areas and and some of the things
she's looking at at the moment is we
know it's a real concern about temporary
accommodation and the amount of people
that are becoming homeless as a a result
of the cost of living crisis so she is
working with the main uh g15 Housing
Association but also with uh MP's
counselors and you know we we're happy
to share information or ideas that we've
got from from that group because the the
themes are the same in rural areas and
the same in in inner cities as well is
the pressures on on um people and our
residents really to sustain their homes
and for those that are becoming homeless
as
well sorry
yeah um so our vision and
plan sorry it's coming up there um that
everyone deserves a quality home that
provides them with the opportunity to
live a better life so one of the
projects we're just starting in the
summer is looking at temporary
accommodation and we are looking with
different councils on that at the moment
and seeing what we can do um what we've
learned as well is we're doing a whole
overhaul of our repairs and maintenance
service because in the last two years it
was a lot of self-reflection and
restructuring really of those teams and
the contractors that we're using we we
use a mixture we've got our own Direct
maintenance teams but we've also got um
uh external contractors for various and
we've also used managing agents and all
those things um need to be managed
effectively um and we we look at ways um
we we're also working with a company
called plentific where if we can't get
those repairs done we're we're managing
those so so that has been a challenge um
but again you know this is what we're
going to be working on our five-year
strategy which I will share with Howard
afterwards and happy to send you some
more information about lnq as well that
you've got to look at in in the future
we're looking at um our approach to
putting residents at the heart of
lnq um we know we haven't always got
that right in the last few years and
we've had sort of a sobering summer
really um where we've had housing
Ombudsman investigations and and a
chance to reflect on those and look at
where we where we've gone wrong quite a
few of those cases date back to the the
beginning of the pandemic but there's
there's no excuses we we have put plans
in place of how we can improve that and
ensure that we do things better um and
so some of that work has been sort of
quite fundamental this year in the
repairs aspect and I'll talk a bit more
about our changes in housing management
and both teams um to sort of provide
that sort of approach I mean we are a
strong organization we're you know a
large organization and trying to
consolidate our financial streng
strength but we can't be complacent um
and that that's one of the things is you
know where are we effectively um going
to deliver and and manage our resources
in the future and look at sort of the
biggest issues that all the sector is
facing at the moment um as we as we
progress um so these are our values for
an organization and and we we ensured
that this is sort of a golden thread
through all all the organization really
of the type of people that we've got so
we are challenging so we're looking at
our values of people you know how are we
responding to residents are we you know
empathetic are we listening to Residents
and are we actually getting back to them
it's our biggest feedback from our
residents is you know get back to us
quickly you know respond to us and make
sure you do and say and do what you're
going to say you're going to do so part
of our role really is both me and Carl
is challenging any behaviors that we see
that are not that but also rewarding the
staff that are working really hard and
nominating them so we have got value
Awards to to demonstrate that and we
want to see passion from staff and um
and passion across the whole of our
teams really and that that's
demonstrated to all our residents um and
we also talk about inclusion we have
local Regional operation um resident
boards that we meet quarterly and so we
have resident representatives from as as
many as we can um some people are on
teams because of the distance and some
people meet in person and we look to see
of ways of how they can shape and
deliver our services going forward um
and from from a responsibility point of
view as we've as we've restructured some
of the Departments it is really making
sure that everyone takes responsibility
from safeguarding from dealing with
repairs being on site and and making
sure that they understand the importance
of what our residents are there for so
we are sort of measuring that and it's
really interesting I know we're going to
talk later about the task and finish
group but the impact of that as well to
make sure that you feel that you know
talking to your talking to Residents
that they are seeing an impact and we
are making a difference so so those
measurements with our key performance
indicators and our targets are delivered
through our appraisals our oneto ones
our team meetings and measured you know
regularly on a weekly
basis um the current team we've got that
manage this area um I I've been um the
head of strategic housing but I'm moving
permanently over to be head of housing
for this team which I'm pleased to be
doing from this month and I hope that we
can build those relationships with you
Carl um knows Carl is the area housing
manager and Carl knows this area very
well he's also managed some of the stock
in this area and he's quite local and
when we've recruited to staff we've
looked at ways of because we're big as
an organization we've looked at agile
working which is is one of our um me uh
benefits of working for lnq but we're
also looking at can we find local staff
that are responsive and can be available
to our residents in this area so Carl
and myself have looked at that and and
and that's we're pleased to say we have
got people that are locally based uh
including Carl um so that's the team we
we will send around um some contact
details as well as the strategy so that
sometimes if you are um having
difficulty because of lmq and you just
want some advice about who's the best
person to speak to in lnq about this it
might be sustainability or other areas
quite a lot of the counselors and MPS
contact us once we've made contact to
give you that sort of you know so you
don't have to spend time trying to find
that out because we appreciate a lar
large
organization
okay so we restructured the housing
management team in June 22 and we've
we've gone back to a adopting a
traditional model of Neighborhood
Housing leads we're calling them they
used to be property managers or tency
management officer or housing officers
um but we're looking at local patches of
approximately 550 homes now we haven't
got as many here at that point in in
Stratford but you know within that area
we feel that is a manageable area for
them to manage now we expect them in
these roles that they're out on their
schemes every you know regularly they
get to know their residents they're
their first point in contact they're
geographically based and they do their
monthly inspections they they apart from
they you know there are are some
residents who would prefer to deal with
us by email or digitally but the fact
we've got a presence there we felt we
went back to basics and and that was one
of the themes that we were talking to
our staff about getting the basic bics
right first time being brilliant at
Basics so some of this um work is around
us being present and residents knowing
like traditionally when I was a housing
officer many meons ago is that they knew
your housing officer and that you were
there and that you were available if
they needed to speak to you so this is
has been in place and we've been
managing change and um settling the
teams down because we did a massive
restructure last year um now some some
staff have have have flown through that
um um process and other people said it's
not really for them so they might have
moved on along the way but part of that
is we are looking for the competencies
as I said about the values of people
that we think are the sort of people we
want that are proactive that can do and
are going to get back to Residence is
our biggest theme and that's how we're
measuring it in recruitment um there is
a challenge and I'm not so sure in in
this area but across the the sector at
the moment is trying to find um the
right sort of people with the right
skills for housing management and
finding it as an attractive post to to
apply for I mean we've the government
have been talking and with legislation
about the professionalism in the service
um which we are making sure that all our
housing uh neighborhood leads are
professionally qualified and so as our
area housing managers so Carl is going
through a new uh chartered Institute of
housing professional qualification at
the moment as one of the area housing
managers so that we cover all the areas
such as building safety and all the
areas that government want to see that
professionalism but part of our role as
well is that is what we want to adopt
and make sure we you know we have that
from all our residents so you know your
customer your counselor and MP inquiries
your customer feedback is really
important to us because that is how we
pick up whether things are working for
us or
not
um sorry um and we've also got the U lnq
Foundation which is part of our um
organization so as apart from the
general needs housing we also offer a
range of support to Residents from
Crisis Support to getting a job um so
some of our money is plowed back in into
the foundation which we see as a really
valuable part of the organization and
particularly in the last few years so
we're looking at ways I I know you were
talking about the citizen advice Bureau
earlier but we working as well we've got
staff employed in lnq and if we can
support residents as well in sustaining
their tency do they need some help um
with employment and um employment and
training and how can we how can we
support them as well so we you know we
work with employment agencies we help
them with their CV it might be something
that we get them a suit to wear for
their interviews um look at ways of you
know within Len q that we can employ
more residents you know to support them
we've got apprenticeship schemes set up
for are all our new builds and
redevelopments and we look as well we've
got a whole team that just support with
budgeting and debt which is becoming you
know a growth area really and and these
are our priorities at the moment within
the foundation and what impact we do so
we look at the social value of that and
we just continue to you know it is quite
a straightforward referral process so we
can send you details of that if you were
ever worried about any of your residents
in this area and also work with Carl and
the team and they will support residents
who we feel might need that
help um also in lnq we've got an area
called lnq living which we provide care
and support services so we house more
than 10,000 vulnerable residents across
London the southeast and Northwest of
England and we directly support people
with mental health illnesses learning
disabilities and older and young people
so we've got kind of an bespoke service
there that from things from sheltered
housing supported housing so we look at
where of how we can work with different
agencies and um housing management and a
agency managed Services as well um so
again you know we can look at ways of um
you know where where are they where how
near are they and what support we could
give to
Residents so we've looked at really the
we've just got that task and finish
survey which is great because we're
we're looking at all the information and
obviously we haven't got loads of data
for lnq yet because we're just coming up
to the two years with you but we're
looking at you know the sort of um
information we've got um within this
area so in the last year we've had 14
complaints logged in the last 12 months
we've got four outstanding at this stage
and they're all at stage one of our
process so we've got two stages of a
process and then it goes to the
Ombudsman I mean you know our aim is
what can we do to help that Resident at
stage one of the process so Carl and his
team would be talking to that
Resident understanding what the reasons
are and what the trends are so we can
pull some of that data for you and and
show you and I'm going to elaborate on
that as well we've got four antisocial
Behavior cases currently we had 13 in
total this year and we've had sort of
through either through customer services
or general inquiries to our Neighborhood
Housing team we've had about 48 108
inquiries this year from the statford
area we do monthly estate inspections
and we're planning surgeries as well
where we can find um the best place to
do a surgery so all our Neighborhood
Housing leads have been given a task of
if you haven't reached your residents
during the day or they haven't contacted
you can we do surgeries for you as well
and we can either use local facilities
like here in the Town Center or uh look
at ways of how we can do that but
monthly we we will do inspections and we
will be walking around the estate and so
you know using our notice boards using
information to try and get as much as we
can and raise our profile with residents
in the
area and so some of the key trends we've
picked up in this area is sometimes
after we've done a Handover in a new
build some of the arrangements with
Aftercare and making sure that's very
structured from a resident point of view
so they've received their keys and then
there's some repairs that need doing and
who does the repair was it a defect was
it so just being a bit more clearer
about that with all our residents so
they understand that and we've explained
the process at sign up and the viewing
so that they're aware of that um we do
use managing agents for some of the work
in this area so again understanding our
relationships there and whether we need
to improve that and we have got some
good managing agents but explaining from
the resident point of view they just
want the works done so that you know
how's that going to work and and
managing if we have gotten issues we're
doing a big project within Len Q in the
moment about managing agents because we
use them across the board and just you
know making sure we get the service we
deliver because of service charges as
well so making sure we manage that as
well GRS maintenance um Carl was saying
as well some of the trees you know some
of the development there on the new
builds just making sure that we've got
the grounds maintenance how we want it
and we're working with residents so that
we improve it as we sort of continue to
build and that you know those trees grow
and and the green and the areas that
they were hoping for when they moved in
it some of it is going to take time um
and then we've also got which we get a
lot from residents how have we
calculated service charges and what does
that mean for the resident when they've
moved in and just explaining the uh
estimates and their actual service
charges um and just spending the time
with residents to go through that so
we've got a Ser specialist service
charge team um and you know we'll work
closely with them so if there's any
queries on that and making sure that
things have been calculated correctly in
the right area and as a very new scheme
making sure we've got it right from day
one we've also um got a specialist um
antisocial Behavior team and a lettings
team as well so we have a lettings team
that coordinate with the nominations
from the local Authority
um so they will um uh arrange for us to
do the viewings and signups and then
we've got a specialist antisocial
Behavior team that deal with Priority
One cases so if we thought there was
risk to life generally most of the cases
we've looked at in in your area are more
that we would expect um Carl and NY
who's the Neighborhood Housing lead to
be involved with investigating in the
first place and we have clear processes
which I'll share with Howard afterwards
and our policies to see you know what we
can can do to deliver that so you know
we we we will manage that under the
tency but if we think the specialist
need um action needs to be taken legal
action under the tency agreement and all
our residents start on a 12 month start
a tency so you know picking up issues
straight away really in their tency from
the day one if we've got concerns or
people haven't settled in very well what
support have we offered them but then
also explain to them the consequences of
their tency
agreement
um so you know it's really great to come
here today we you know we would love to
work more with you and and some more
partnership working we are preparing all
the data that you've asked for on the
task and finish group and as you said
you would like that monthly so we can
collate that and um and identify that
for you and and that will also give us
um we can give a focus on it to any any
issues that come up um as I said we were
hope to aim with the local surgeries and
have a presence here keeping regular
updates and we're happy if if you wanted
to call quy meetings with us or any
meetings we we'll work with in the way
you want us to um I just wanted to say
as well counselor and MP inquires were
were taken they were logged within a
centralized team and we did have quite a
few issues there in the summer so I'm
sorry there was quite a few delays on
those and um they've they've recruited
some new staff now and we will make sure
that you know we are meeting a service
level agreements because we appreciate
during sort of five to six months there
was quite a few where they were quite
out update so we are working on those
and we will continue to do so and after
this meeting we'll make sure we share
all our regular information so if you
want an instant answer or something that
you haven't got um details of that you
contact you can contact me on Carl and
we'll try and get that for you in in
advance I think that was I think then it
was just any questions if there was any
questions you want to
ask R are you indicating you want to
open the butt in there please
o okay let let me start um a lot of what
I have to say I think needs to be done
as a task and finish group because I
don't think it's fair on the rest of the
people around this table to hear
individual gripes and and queries
there's just uh a couple of things I
need to say first of
all
I have no idea about counselor and mp uh
thing I am the town district and
counselor for this development in Oak
Road and neither of you have ever ever
contacted me
ever okay you've not reached out to me
all the residents would rather speak to
me than speak to you mostly because they
never get anything back from you I'm the
one that ends up talking to you and I
don't get anything back from you either
the district council here have trouble
contacting you they have real trouble
you getting back to them there is an
outstanding enforcement case on the open
area there I we can't go into too much
detail firstly I want to know and and
for the sake of people around the table
um you built some of the houses in Oak
Road and you social you you are the
social landlord for the social housing
on the Spitfire
development so I kind of want to know
how that adds up to 295
homes because it doesn't figure in my
you know I I look after all these homes
they're all in my ward and there aren't
295 homes believe me there are 270 homes
on Arden Heath you only look after the
social housing aspect of half of those
okay
and there's the 46 houses on Oak Road
that you built and you look after the
social housing aspect of um those on
that development and you built the 46
houses so I'm I'm at a losses to to
understand how you've got to
houses so um you you talk about um um
firstly getting the basics right so let
me go back to the very beginning when
you first came uh with uh an
application um it took um planning to
say no this isn't looking right you need
to work with the counselor and a team of
residents which you actually did and it
worked out that you built in the end a
very nice looking
development it needed some it needed
some working from us and we worked
together and you built a very very nice
development originally it wasn't a very
nice development like most developments
it comes forward and they all look like
Legoland but you did actually come
forward in the end with a reasonably Nic
looking
development however your quality of
build is not that brilliant um and some
of them um I find it very odd that some
of your houses um have damp and mold and
they're less than 10 two years old a lot
of this really should be taken as part
of the task and finish group but I I I
really take issue with your um we aim to
get Basics right and we deal with
residents and we want a good um
relationship with
residents this morning I whatsapped and
emailed to several residents on the
development and I asked them to come
back with
um with things that um they wanted me to
say to you some of it I can't really
repeat and some of it's not fair I say
now um but let me just give you a couple
of things um one says your management
company
Encore um they're rude they're not
accountable they're poor they don't get
back to the
residence and they need to be replaced
with a more efficient
company uh and the other point is um lnq
must improve their communication with
tenants uh many tenants contact you and
you don't get back to them they end up
contacting me I contact you and you
don't get back to
me I don't think that's very fair so um
I I did I did want to try and I've got
lots of little itty itty itty bits that
I don't think is appropriate for this
meeting but I I I do take issue with I
mean coun and MP inquiries I'm the only
counselor I've never contacted you on
that ever I don't even know how to
contact you on that and and and yet
you're saying that you've had lots of
questions on it I've never questioned
you on that if I just jump in there yeah
right I'll bring you in second lots of
points there Kate and I'll perh bring
you back in a
bit if I can give Carl and Angela a
chance to respond to some of them and
then we'll bring some other Cancers and
then right at the end I can bring you
back in just so everyone fair chance and
there's a lot to take in I appreciate
that made so K if you could if there's
things that been missed you could come
back councelor off and come back on that
so so if you do miss some cart don't
worry about it we we'll remind you
that's fine so yeah if you want to come
back with those and then we'll bring
some other counselors in thank you
that's fine so uh again my name's KL
Rose I'm the area housing manager uh for
this region um would like to
say um again thank you for coming
councelor rol I've met with councelor
Rolf as a Neighborhood Housing lead um
before I was promoted to manager um I've
met with counselor on site in Residence
homes um one resident in particular yeah
sorry about that well I was in the role
for a short period of time so it was
three months four months I was actually
NHL in that time meeting councelor rol
she had expressed concerns with London
and quadrant
and how she wanted to see improvements
um totally accepting of councilor Ro's
comments uh most definitely Justified
I've been working for lin Q now since
2015 so I've seen areas that we need to
improve in um and obviously some of her
comments have been warranted um some
comments spanned from housing management
perspective but also go from a
development perspective and also a
repairs perspective so they cross the
departmental issues that we kind of have
in across the organization um again
councelor Rolf is right and we love
working with vocal counselors that want
to make sure we're delivering services
for our residents so a lot of her
comments that have come forward we've
taken them very seriously um I think in
some
instances our first interactions of you
dealing with the Neighborhood Housing
lead instead of the stakeholder team I
think May of
again hampered some relationships or you
I think in instance you would have got a
prompter response because the
neighborhood hous leads on the ground
the the stakeholder team is a department
who just generate the responses in a
sense for yourself so we do apologize
about that and we can share that
information with you the way that we
work internally now is once you do
contact that team it is forwarded on to
the managers like myself and Angela now
I know your preview to my personal email
address and I haven't had much inquiries
come through in the last few months
while I've been managing a team of nine
officers um and again apologies for not
reaching out in that period of time
counselor rool because you're definitely
someone that we want to maintain
relationships with as I've explained to
my boss prior to this meeting um so do
want to apologize for you on that point
and yes we should have stuck with uh
quarterly visits and meetings with
yourself which we'll try to get
reestablished um so I just wanted to
cover that point but definitely
appreciate all of council Ro's comments
she holds us accountable and is very
again on on site and and speaking with
our residents so thank you very much for
that um just wanted to touch on a few
points so the after care issue that we
have um with our services at the moment
um a lot of things were planned um or
promised to Residents and I think some
of those promises have fell through lnq
has looked at what we overpromise at as
well um and to make sure that we're more
reasonable Windows moving forward and
looking at those Lessons Learned but
again the staff that we have on the
ground in respect of our nhls and our
expectations you know we we expect them
not to just focus on housing management
aspects within their role and focus on
take responsibility for all issues so if
it's an after care issue they will
escalate and support that resident in
getting those answers from those
departments and I think that's where
some of the communication tends to break
down because you're having to work with
other officers in that that instance um
but again I
feel once we our officers in regards to
the locality the officer we have nigh at
the moment he currently lives at the top
end of London so we are hoping to get
him moved um and have a more local
officer but I feel with the restructure
of Staff um he'd actually fell into that
role and that's why he's occupying at
the moment but I believe going forward
we will have someone centrally based
even myself because I'm going back to my
previous roles at NHL so we might be
meeting next year councelor roof um
because I'm covering a maternity cover
and again I'm I'm much local to the
region but I have expressed this to my
line manager in the growth that we're
doing in the region and making sure we
have those officers so irrespective if
I'm the officer I believe elink will
have someone more local um who again can
be aware of commun community issues be
onsite two to three times a week with
our residents and I think that's the
service we're delivering down in the
South and it's slowly coming up here I
think the issue we have at the moment is
the stock numbers and and just to go
back on councelor R's point about the
stock numbers so in order for us to have
an official patch an employer an officer
we're looking at roughly about 500 units
for each patch um and and I think we're
what we've done with strapford upon aen
we have limited stock in that un unit as
councilor rool as has mentioned but we
what happens because that's not enough
units to make a patch you we've got
properties in centry and rugby which
have probably been captured in those
numbers so do apologize about that
councelor Ro if there was any
discrepancies but I think that's how
we've kind of built the team I believe
once and we're all got resource
restrictions um we've currently lifted a
recruitment ban um so I think for us
we're we're kind of going to be looking
at restructuring pack is more once we
get more growth in the area but I'll
just make Angela jump
in yeah I think uh like you said sorry
to hear that you know we're we're not
making that impression and like you said
the WhatsApp messages from the residents
so I think when we go back both me and
Carl and if we speak tonight get an
action plan can we just have the
specific issues that you've got or if I
um can share we can share our email
address and you can send them to us and
we'll get you updates on that um in
response to to that um I'm going to
suggest to you that we don't go on
specifics but that between us we
organize a residents meeting with
yourselves so all the residents that
have issues can come and meet with you
and we can deal with the whole lot in
one go because I haven't got the time or
the patience or the energy to take
individual issues and go backwards and
forwards and not get replies and get
half-hearted replies and I'll be on site
such and such a time and you don't turn
up so I would like to organize with
yourselves a meeting with as many
residents as possible and yourselves if
that's possible thank you that will
solve all those issues yeah thank you we
set that up we can set that up we're
looking at we've just recently done pmrs
um for our offices so one of those
objectives is local surgeries and
newsletters so that is an option for for
the NHL n at this present moment between
now and April to have that set up and
again we're looking for any local um
community centers or offices that we
need to come what's really sorry just to
go back on that what's very
important is that when we decide a date
and a time that I tell the residents and
not you and the reason being is they
more likely to turn up if I tell them
rather than if you tell them if that's
okay I think probably best if if both
both tell you both we we'll write to
them as well yeah and tell them but
again if if you're poorly for some
reason that would I think it would be
best for both parties because we've got
social residents as she explained and
we've also got shared ownership res
that's what I was going to say and just
some people might not be able to make
the meeting but if you give give us an
idea where the best place to have the
meeting that would be great as well yeah
yeah thank you thank you yeah I think
some of these can perhaps be discussed
the fin details after the meeting but I
think the principle about cancel the
surgeries and or your surgeries as well
it is a fair one I do think the
communication again from yourselves
involving cancel elf but I think it's
best that two both of you contact them
just to make sure um obviously if you
only have one meeting there will always
be people who can't
attend uh so that's that's another issue
and whether you could have something
like um Regular ad hoc meetings um I
know it's a bit of oxymoron there isn't
it um regular meetings you know so
people can put these things forward on
um in the the communication as well um
again lots of things whether you've got
any um Facebook uh page any uh Twitter
Instagram Etc on C the harmer will be
able to voice me better on the
terminology there
um well we do it between us anyway so um
so I think that would be better
communication um so I think that is is
really important and again the Lessons
Learned I think the other things as well
in in my area service charges and
management companies are are an issue as
well so again we need to look on that
but I've I've rambled on enough that oh
pmrs that's the other so just two points
I just want to say so in regards to pm
he doesn't know what is
yes so they're appraisal so they're mid
performance reviews that we do so set of
object objectives are set on our uh each
employee in the organization our nhls um
have objectives and again the customer
focus is at the heart of that and it
sets up objectives in regards to being
responsive knowing who your nhls are um
what you're doing um to promote and
improve Services across your schemes so
those are General onetoone meetings or
six Monon reviews that we have and and
and like I've said one of those
objectives is to ensure you have uh two
two to four surgeries I think roughly
throughout the annual 12 months on your
s um and I think again because of the
dispers of those those sites in
particular for this officer we just need
to make sure we're doing those with
councelor rool in that aspect um there
was another point that I was going to
touch on was regarding Encore um the
management company so lnq um a lot of
the external Services have been set out
for a management agent to to take over
now lnq have been using two local
managing agents which I think hopefully
you guys are known well known of so
we've got Trinity estat and enor um we
have found Trinity Estates to to be not
the best managing agent and at times
we've had to change which has caused
disruptions which which councilor rool
may have been copied into but in regards
to Ron call um we understand that they
may not be the best management company
and we're we're monitoring them and
again from what I've found and I think
from what the NHL's found they they are
very responsive in that respon to us so
I think it's just making sure that
residents are communicating via US so
that we're again holding our contractors
accountable um and again apologies if
any residents have direct directly gone
to Encore and not got the service that
they should have expected and I think
acoss the board that's what lnq tried to
ensure that our residents I mean I've
worked as a housing officer several
years ago and we don't want our
residents going through to our
contractors maybe because we're
conscious and we want to make sure we're
demonstrating those values so it's
always a requirement for them to come
through to us so that we can manage
those relationships so I think again
we'll pick up on some of those instances
where residents have made concerns about
the service so that we overcome those
and bring those up with our management
companies we do meet on site of our
management companies fortnightly um I
receive and they do send us some high
quality images of what they've seen what
they've resolved on site we receive
photos um we receive monthly reports on
what they've done again I think there's
an understanding about new builds from
what I've seen and I'll give you pros
and cons um with the social residents
again a lot of these residents are
moving into their firsttime homes um
they've
never I think the quality of the homes
in from what I've got from residents
they've been very pleased on and from
what I've seen we're providing a very
high void standard I'm I'm referring
back to some of the concerns that you've
mentioned about residents moving in
without white goods we're moving
residents in with white goods washing
machines fridges beds mattress carpets
blinds we're doing a lot of that in our
homes um and again going back to
counselor's um comment on the quality of
the build all of our properties are
built to the the new new building
standards
regulations
um there's always going to be snagging
issues and and and things that need to
be done I believe on large scale
projects um and that is something that
our delivery team are working on making
sure that our the contractors that we're
working with Spitfire bway all of those
organizations are held accountable and
delivering high quality products and
services for our residents so that's
something that I been working with the
delivery team and development team on
and I can see the enthusiasm and the
passion in those meetings to make sure
that those products are delivered to a
standard again there are instances where
they haven't met those standards but
we're trying I can see from an inside
point from lq we do try to hold those
accountable and I think we need to just
make sure the residents are are aware of
of what we're doing also um that's on
the social side again on the shared
ownership side and I think this isn't
just an issue for Stratford upon aen I
think it's across the whole of London
with shared ownership I think a lot of
people when they buy into that
product um are not fully aware of what
they're buying into and that's probably
a mistake on behalf of lq's standpoint
and probably a sales and and solicitor
standpoint to make sure that the person
that's buying that product understands
that they will be liable for certain
charges and I think that's where an
issues also come up in respect of why
why are we paying for this why are we
paying for that um just and again with
lnq I think what we tend to do we tend
to try to own those problems and resolve
them before referring them to Citizens
advice bureaus before referring them to
lease advisory services and I think
probably in that the residents field
they've only got one face to discuss
those concerns and it is an educational
kind of standpoints in a sense your your
legal obligations in your lease so I
think if we give more um options for
them to to have those discussions with
those different Services it will educate
them on what they've actually bought
into and I believe there has been
particular cases which lnq have um kind
of high prioritized and worked with
residents and kind of Taken on board
their comments and probably in some
sense probably compensated them for some
of the concerns that they have raised we
have a very good compensation policy um
residents who feel they've been met by
distress or
inconveniences um in our services or
disruptions we have a good will we have
a Goodwill payment system and
compensation process which we do provide
to our residents where those those
issues do
arise um
I again some of the sites and the
development sites again lnq I feel at
times we have moved residents in before
they have been finished and I think
that's an issue at some times as well
where shared owners have bought a
product a finished product which have
seen virtually and they're expecting you
know for it to just look exactly like
that and I think that's where we've also
let residents down where we've not
completed an entire development and
we've had six months of sections
probably still undergoing Handover or
even reembedding we're talking about new
land new dirt new so that needs to take
trees also again which have been planted
which look beautiful virtually and
Beautiful on firsthand but allor is
actually taken in the new so and and
maintaining those trees and the grounds
and
services again the the watering issue is
an issue which myself and councilor
roolf discussed and um we looked at we
looked at um we looked at that and how
the it could have been incorporated into
the service charges and I believe the
reason why we haven't Incorporated it is
because of the service charge impact
that that would have on the residence
given the current climate at the moment
in respect of having a tanker to walk
around or to travel around to those
sites to water those trees it would be
impactful on service charges so I think
we've looked at replacing those trees
where they die because it's more cost
effective um and a less of an impact on
the service charges when those incidents
do occur
so do apologize do
apologize that's the watering company
that's how you going
around right I I'll bring some questions
in briefly um yeah I think that that one
there there's probably plan and
obligations and we need to look at that
um I've got councelor Wally hoggins
cancor Johnson cancor fie cancel keithy
cancor hmer oh oh cancel kiy so cancor
Wally hoggins first
please hello um as you know I'm chairing
the the task and finish group I think
really that what a lot of this boils
down to with the housing associations
and there are horror stories Galore I
have to say that
um most of this boils down to reputation
and the people within your organization
it's not just the people that are being
paid by L andq it's also the contractors
that you have just bear with me for a
moment please and and actually I was
fairly horrified when you put the slide
up about the values of the organization
because actually the word passionate was
the word that stuck out at me that is
completely not what is required in order
to run a a decent and proper Housing
Association what actually should be up
there in my considered opinion is
actually
um to have to be honorable to be kind
and also to have integrity and what
really bothers me it got even worse
because then you told me that your
employees you know he helping they've
got an incentive scheme now and I wonder
please if this incentive scheme you
don't have have to answer this now you
perhaps need to go away and think about
it because if that incentive scheme is
based on I don't know points mean prizes
just for want of a better phraseology
here if that's based on the number of
cases closed the number of people
they've dealt with you know finished off
with that you know then you said about
the photographs oh we've dealt with this
you know how do you know how do you know
that that is what's happening or are
they closing cases which happens nearly
in every single Housing Association are
they're saying that they're closed and
actually they're not finished with but
then they get their their reward for
kind of getting through that sorry I
have got more questions but but do
answer that for me because that's really
important but no I don't like the word
passionate because you can be passionate
about anything to get a job but actually
what you need is people that really do
care about those in their care and that
integrity and honorability I know
they're very oldfashioned terms but
actually in this society that we find
ourselves in they're sadly lacking thank
you your microphone won't work oh sorry
okay thank you um yeah no I I hear what
you're saying um I mean I think you do
need to I I appreciate what you're
saying on your feedback but I think you
do need to have some passion in the job
because you've got to have an interest
in why you're doing housing and that you
care about housing and you care about
residents so that's some of the the
values um we don't I mean I think it's
usually we can tell straight away really
with our residents cuz we we we get a
lot of positive feedback we get five
star trust pilot reviews from about our
our staff and thank you cards and
someone that's gone that extra mile so
they're the people that kind of get
nominations for awards um you know
there's there's certain expectations in
the job that that that's a given that is
what you're expected to do it's these
people that we saying where we reward
them is where they've gone that extra
Mar where they really have shown it and
it's usually from residents feedback
stakeholders people that have come back
back to us and said I just really wanted
to say what brilliant job uh that
person's done so so that's how we
measure it we we AIT um we audit we have
a dashboard on our d365 which is our our
system and you're right that sometimes
when we go back and we do an audit Trail
I can complete investigations we've got
key performance indicators that are
measured in a senior management team on
a monthly basis we've got a quality
reassurance team and they will drill out
data so we can see if people are just
closing down queries closing down
complaints um and that would be tackled
and managed under our HR procedures
about why they're doing that because
they might have a clear dashboard but
they're not dealing with the issues that
the residents have raised because
everything's logged through the contact
center but then we've got staff that go
out on on our scheme and you know we we
are working hard it is one of the things
that we are still sort of working with
our staff and I'm sorry you know to hear
the feedback today about communication
getting back to Residents when you say
you're going to get back to them they
we've got 5 days to respond to queries
getting back opening your emails
responding to your emails and making
sure you're doing that so that is
something that we we're we're monitoring
and as I said we haven't got it all
right yet but we are you know working
towards improving that but so we use the
data we also use the values and when we
do Competency Based interviews we are
looking for the sort people that do care
you know the questions are around how
you know how would you deal in this
situation dealing with a resident who
may be vulnerable give them scenarios
and it's quite telling usually in
interviews the people that want to care
and and and want to do that for
residents if I just jump in quickly
sorry just to goore on your point so
your point about about caring as well I
think we've put that in in our people
category and um about caring for res so
and the Integrity part of it which you
agree with I love those words I think
we've kind of fit those under the
responsibility kind of value um in
respect of the description and just to
find how we meet that but just to touch
on the review of cases you're totally
right managers like ourselves you know
we're responsible for our staff and
making sure that we're reviewing their
work I think we have a 10% review it was
just yesterday that I reopened a
complaint which I feel one of my
officers had closed without taking the
correct action so I feel we have a
structure where management can review
and see data of cases high priority
cases especially complaints where if
we're not not satisfied with that
response we can draw that back and again
work with that member of staff to try
and achieve the best outcome for the
resident so I just wanted to touch back
on that because we we do see in I've
seen incidents I think when you have
people come into a company you're right
you know you give them trust you believe
that they're here to do a great job but
it takes time for you to kind of as a
manager to see what that individual is
actually doing and see what their
feedback is and I think over a few
months we're able to identify if these
people have those characteristics and if
they don't either develop them and
support them to get them where we want
them to be or in effect performance
manage them out in in in
respectfully sorry just one followup
please if you just switch your
microphone off um could you tell tell us
please how you manage the maintenance
teams so you're Outsourcing it currently
I think so it's how are you how are you
as a company then how do you oversee the
quality of the work they're doing and
managing their response times um to to
to those issues and latterly and you
don't have to answer this question now
but I would also like to know how you
are
communicating um the philanthropic um
elements what we've told us today about
the helping people with apprenticeships
and buying uh suits and uniforms that
kind of thing uh because certainly
moving forward that's something that we
are going to need as a there but it is
that managing the maintenance teams
because with all well in the world that
is what matters coming along and fixing
something and not kicking the can down
the line especially important as we
enter the cold weather period thank you
very much indeed um yeah we we've got a
a mixture we have we have got some
direct maintenance teams and we've also
got external contractors as well so it
is a combination we're doing a a massive
repairs change project so as well as us
having a restructure last year the whole
they're overhauling the repairs and
maintenance team we hold them to account
because we will what we work closely in
in neighborhood teams with the the
repairs team so we've got staff within
there we will look at the performance
data the kpis for the repairs service um
that we're looking at firsttime fix
which I think is at 80% um at the moment
but it is these jobs that I always say
go down this black hole so it's a bit
complicated someone goes out and looks
at it then someone else comes out and
look at it and then we've got four
people that have gone out and looked it
and no one's fixed it and they're the
jobs that this is the the cold hard the
Ombudsman review really in the summer of
you know sorry how are we're going to do
that better um so the feedback from our
staff from the housing management teams
is you know if they pick up when they go
on site that the contractors are not
responding not doing that but they are
answerable to senior management team the
executive team in terms of how they meet
those kpis and the and and we as a
housing management team um will be
responsible as part of the senior
management team in in housing to to make
sure that we provide that feedback and
we're part of the repairs change
management groups as well to make sure
they do things better in the future
because we know we haven't got it right
um and I think as a large organization
these are where things do fall down and
you know we've had to learn the hard way
really um and we appreciate that and
that's something our chief executive
owner and the executive team are looking
at you know to make sure we we we
improve that so I think we're on a
journey we're not there yet um but we
are working but any customer feedback we
get from residents that they're not
happy with the contractors that have
gone out please let us know because you
know we will quantify that and make sure
that is captured and fed back as
well just to jump in on that point I
mean again if any managing agent isn't
performing to the standards that we
think that they should be there will be
stages that we will take we've got an
internal legal team so if we feel
they're not being responsive there's um
patterns of behavior in response to them
not delivering Services before going
legal with them to damage that
relationship we have our own legal team
um and again if that doesn't improve we
can go to FTE to to have them removed at
that instance I think what will happen
again and an lnq is new to the region
and this is what I've stressed to my
manager we are the new players in in in
your county um and I think for Len from
what I know as well I think once we get
more established in your region and and
build those contractual relationships
with you know those professional
businesses in the area they'll be able
to provide again more of a responsive
service to our residents we're tied into
a lot of agreements at the moment um
we've had warranties that we've had to
be tied into so our contractors in
effect can't touch certain items during
that period it's it's it's held
accountable to the developers so it's
that relationship that are off theare
team have had as well where I've spoken
to a lot of their staff and again
getting the those Developers back to
sight to be held accountable for the
work that they're doing sometimes hasn't
been the easiest job but I think they've
held them accountable to make sure that
we it doesn't go to a legal stance but
you're totally right the resident
doesn't see that side and all they see
is long- winded um repairs and no
responses and I think behind the scenes
that's that's what's going on but not
explained to the resident and we need to
improve on that going forward also in
respect to our welcome packs information
we neighborhoods is the management
company but if you have an after care
issue you're waiting for a response from
after care and if that department
doesn't respond it impacts the whole
organization and I think this is the
message that we've also had with those
managers of those teams they're
responsible for those that relationship
not primarily but they have an impact on
those relationships for our Neighborhood
Housing leads and it's important I've
personally ver voiced this with those
managers in that department that they
are held accountable to also respond
into residents where required because
what tends to happen is they just get
escalated to housing management and then
we have to step in on those apartment so
just wanted to cover those points on
that thank you thank you can yes cancor
Johnson
please always concerned that you've got
I think you said 234 properties out of
100,000 in
Stratford um
and be grateful if you could describe in
a fair amount of detail
what is the
organizations's uh you know who is
responsible for the service from your
organization you talked about a
Neighborhood Housing
lead um responsible for 550 homes so
there's 300 missing somewhere where are
they um who's the Neighborhood Housing
lead and are they really based in North
London because this seems to me to
be a structure that's just going to fail
it's not can you describe it and could
you describe the responsibility of your
um managing
agents and how do we know how to find
how ultimately can we find our way
through all this that alone going back
to the developer as
well um yeah I mean I know we said we
haven't got all the 550 in in this area
not I is our Neighborhood Housing lead
we we we we are you know part of our job
is being an agile worker so they will
you know they will be out on their patch
that is the aim of a Neighborhood
Housing lead they need to be out on the
road out and visiting their patch so
some of it is going to be here some of
it is rugby warrener um centry So within
within this area um and I know we're a
large organization but we have
infrastructures like our customer
services teams we're set up up to to
accommodate that so we don't all have to
be sitting in the you know since the
pandemic I think that's been
demonstrated isn't it we don't all have
to be in the one space for us to deliver
Services um we are a large organization
and we we are set up to do that so we've
got every you know everywhere from
Sussex right up to Manchester but we but
what we try and do is is try and make
that locally based and although Carl is
looking to recruit to a locally based
person in this area to make them attra
but Carl is local as well and as he's
the area housing manager he would
respond if we felt there was a concern
and come out because he's with you know
he's he's able to travel here quickly so
we we would provide that service but a
lot of what our residents ask for are
things that we can deal with over the
phone or a lot of them communicate with
email to us um but those residents who
would like a visit or we do tency visits
as part of our our role as well as
Neighborhood Housing leads we will go
and visit them explain about their St
ATT tendency and then manage that
through there
so so that's the setup we've got it is
right across you know we are a large
organization like you said
105,000 and we have got a lot of
residents but it's it's we've got
Regional teams everywhere who are
managing those those specific areas so
we've got Northwest London and we've got
um you know statford and warshire as
part of that region so that that is how
we're set up but we've got all locally
based people in these teams to deliver
those Services because we're all trying
to the same one
just on the role of managing agents
Sor thank you so um on these sites the
way that the Deeds have been set up in
respect of lnq as the Freeholder um but
we've appointed managing agents to
manage the communal Services um so I
think that's benefited us because they
have local contractors that they could
use to manage those Services whether it
be Grounds Maintenance that responsible
for for the cleaning on sites on roads
that haven't been adopted by the council
um also block services and we don't have
a lot of blocks here which is great it's
mainly houses but on those in communial
blocks they may manage services like the
cleaning of that block um the door entry
system um servicing of that and the fire
alarm systems and any aov systems in
those buildings effectively once the if
the resident was to report a fault on
those systems through our call centers
the NHL who is the housing officer sorry
um would report that to the managing
agent because they're responsible for
those services on those buildings and
then we would expect them to resolve
that within a timely manner which tends
to match up with our slas um we have
emergency repairs for 4 hours to 24
hours and then routine repairs which
could take up to 20 working days and
those are our two priorities that we
have apart from planned Works um which
could be three months or annually for
major work kind of improvements um but
yeah in respect of the management of
those services on those schemes they are
carried out by the managing agent and
and you're right we do need to make sure
that um they their their slas and what
they're give the service they're
delivering matches what we want and we
need to continually to monitor those to
make sure that they are
delivering question thank you uh
bringing councelor fragile
place thank you
chair
um I was going to ask you where these
295 houses are but it's apparent that
they're probably in tiddington
um sorry
Kate but but for the future are you
concentrating for further developments
in Stratford Town itself or are you
going to other towns in the Strat
District such as shipston and of course
are you looking at the rural areas of
the of the district I'm talking about
the District of Stratford not just
warshire thank
you I'm not sure we've got anything
major planned in statford at the moment
um they they're the ones we're doing
because we're looking we have got some
in the pipeline but they're going to be
more rugby war Shar so nothing you know
that would be something maybe working
with the local Authority um to do to do
that but nothing nothing else major
planned for development here at the
moment in Stratford yeah we we we're
looking M we have got some development
pipelines that are already committed to
but they're not in the Town Center or
straford at the moment no but they're in
rugby and
warshire and just to point on that those
are sites that I think the land space
has been available for them to develop
large development schemes I've seen them
myself so we tend to have about 3 to 500
properties on on that grand space of
land and some still being developed
personally from what I can see on the
ground um and I've fed this SP
management as well we're probably on
those areas growing in about the next
I'd say 100 or so every every few years
um so there's definitely still some
development in those areas going
on counc
hmer thank you chair um I do think it is
rather quite telling that kind of a lot
of the questions you've had have been
about fleshing out processes and
structures um and just a friendly bit of
advice I would have if you come doing
this forward um is that you are talking
to a group of politicians um we are very
good at recognizing when someone is
saying something with quite a lot of
words but with not quite with not a lot
of substance
because we tend to do that quite a lot
um so I think what I'd like to know
about is what what you touched on very
very briefly um is given you're dealing
with new housing with new with new
builds um I'm kind of of a cohort where
some of my more fortunate colleagues and
contemporaries um are in the process of
buying their first house and there are
quite a lot of horror stories in the
sector at the moment of kind of these
houses not being built up to standard
and you said you kind of you touched on
that briefly and kind of you know with
with examples so I would like to know
kind of what processes you actually have
to stand up for Resident residents where
contractors and Builders just haven't
done their due diligence and where
things aren't done to the standard that
they should be
yeah can you put your thing on please
sorry um we have uh end of defects
inspections again which our delivery
team and our preconstruction team carry
out so before the before the end of that
liability period the developer and the
contractors and our delivery teams will
go out on site they visit each property
and go through the snagging list of what
the issues are in that home technically
I've made sure that that is done because
I've come from a maintenance background
and Co Center work so you know even
though I've moved to management I'm
trying to make sure that those
departments are have have those
processes in place and are ensuring that
the con our residents aren't just moving
in there is an end of defect inspection
that is carried out so I think like just
to answer your question there are
departments who have processes in place
to help those contractors accountable um
and if they don't legally we can flect
them up as lat and defects which we can
again hold them to we have got um we can
show you the development processes and
procedures because they would be part of
their Handover process so we can if you
want us to share any of that information
we can speak to them yeah yeah I think
that would be useful because again like
basically what you what you've done with
that answer is basically say well we
have one but you know I think I think
for a pres you know for things like this
it would be useful for us if we were
able to properly see that it is fleshed
out and considered and that we know
what's going on so thank
you yeah I'll let councelor off have the
last word when she's the expert on this
one it's not very often I'll let
councelor off have the last word anyway
so I
will take it any I will be um I we
bringing um yeah just couple things
points I noticed first time finishes
yeah that's really important 80% if you
can get those high and again four people
com out to seeing the same thing oh
that's a hole oh yeah we're oh yeah
that's a hoe and you get fed up with
that communication around the warranties
I think that's a point yeah particularly
around the trees Etc and again it's all
about Communications and if you're
having regular surgeries these can come
out and then you know other people then
can do the work for you you one night
butti another one um the expectations
and rights again when people are moving
in you know obviously they will probably
have a pack coming in but perhaps that
could explain more again save you time
in the long run so I think that's some
some key points that could come out um
so yeah that's really point and
councelor R come on in
please thank you chair uh you didn't uh
I've got a few things I need to say you
didn't answer the question about
counselor and MP team because I have
never ever been on that site and asked a
question so I don't know who else is
getting on that site asking you
questions about your development because
I'm the only one that can do that that's
um uh and I'd like you to look into that
because you did say there are many
outstanding emails on there old emails
I've never contacted that site I've
contacted it about orbit but never about
um lnq so I'm going to go back to um a
very simple um 106 agreement that you
had when you built the development on
Oak Road and your 106 agreement was to
make good that um open area put trees
put grass down and make it uh user
friendly currently it's completely
unuser friendly it's completely unusable
now you are telling residents that if
you do any more work they are going to
have to pay on their management it's got
nothing to do with them to have to pay
it's your job to do it properly do it
correctly and until it's done the
residents that live there should have no
no need to pay for anything now I've had
I've had residents come to me saying
we've been threatened by you saying if
they do any more work they will have to
you will have to increase their their uh
management fees that is
absolutely not on um and and I know that
this is with enforcement and and I don't
know how far enforcement have got but
it's up to you to water those trees you
plant them you water them if you don't
and and don't charge the residents for
doing it you're there you keep saying
you're there every week water them okay
that that area needs grassing grass it
that area needs to be used by the people
that live on that development make it
usable don't charge Char the residents
for doing it when it comes to new build
I've I've I spent many years as an
estate agent I'm asham shamed to say
selling new developments okay and I know
what new developments should be like and
I have never come across new houses
showing damp and mold there is the block
of flats there that didn't have the
guttering attached to the roof the water
was pouring down inside the walls and
outside the walls please don't tell me
these are minor defects and snagging
areas this is Major this is major
building disaster so that that's the
point you're not to charge the
residence and one last thing um um and
Angela you know sorry sorry I'm and you
know and I hope we can start again
freshly in January but when you say to
me Carl knows the area
well he doesn't really he's been there a
few times he doesn't know that area he
doesn't know it like the residents do
and like I do it and no never has Carl
reached out to me to ask me a question
ever so please try and be a little bit
more transparent work both ways let's
start again in January I'm going to set
up a meeting I'm going to find out from
the residents when it's convenient it
may it may have to be after work it may
well in fact it will have to be after
working hours
um to accommodate as many people as
possible but let's all get together and
try and eyon out these problems and stop
charging the residents for doing
something that you are obliged to do as
part of your planning conditions thank
you say thanks no started say you finish
very good very good um I think I won't
expect answers but on on now I think
what would be good now is uh some
synopsis of some of the points that
you've learned from this meeting um some
of the things where you you you you
admit that things haven't gone as well
as you should uh bits about the m is
obviously a key Point things like that
um some details of when you're likely to
have some of these meetings and and
things like that just so I as chair of
this meeting have some reassurance that
we've there's been proper two-way
communication we've both listened we've
both communicated and the message has
been received and understood properly so
I think about Mee
so yeah so again the award member uh and
again that that's that's really good um
so I think there's lots of learning
points thank you for coming car you can
definitely speak for England so well
done you make a good counselor uh very
good there is only one one one there was
no puns so I slightly disappointed out
that but but no it's very good so thank
you for turning up today thank you for
coming into the Bear Pit and and
listening to to us so and thank you
having names that are nice and easy to
pronounce so I don't make make any
mistakes know that so but yeah if you
could just give us that undertaken that
you'll you'll come back to us um and
I'll get details from from her that'll
be great so thank very
much we have got the next item on the
agenda councelor cus are you okay if we
have a break for two minutes and then
we'll be back refreshed
yeah so sure it'll be worth waiting
for so we will be back I want to be back
hopefully by 11:55 so it's 3 minutes
break
right then and now moving on to item
eight which is member question time oh
where's he
G
right and we'll be talking today with
councilor Curtis a supported by Mr Burl
um about the items on budget and finance
audit and risk internal audit and
ICT so I can whil I'm
filling can I have an indication of who
wants to ask some questions once we've
started or we uh or we'll wait till
listen to
um
I put some questions
yeah yeah if you put for
yourself councel Curtis we're in your
hands
now we're in your hands would you like
to a brief presentation or are you happy
to go in with a questions or
I'll I've got a briefing note I'll make
a few comments on that I think
everyone's had the briefing note um just
a couple of comments if I to start with
on that
um the
first first sections up to five are
there are is no change from The Briefing
note which I'm sure all members updated
themselves from January last year so
there's no change there um on page four
the external audit the council's the
bottom sentence there council's annual
accounts have always received an
unqualified audit opinion we'll touch on
that in one of the other written
questions um going on to page five key
developments and issues um financial
planning just a a little comment on this
that because we have continually had and
continue to continue to have one-year
settlements um just drawing everyone's
attention to the last sentence of the
second
paragraph we have to set aside High
probably additional reserves than we
would ideally like to and I'm sure Mr B
will correct me if I'm saying anything
wrong here but because we have to ensure
against all the various unknowns
particularly at the moment when there is
so much volatility not just in the UK
but
worldwide um we we need those additional
reserves to protect ourselves from any
unexpected shocks but of course as it
says this ties up resources that could
otherwise be used to the benefit of the
district if the risk of UNF funding
unknown funding was
removed hopefully if you know if there
may well be an election next year and we
may
see um may see a change of Direction and
longer term longer term funding for
local authorities which would be to
everyone's
benefit um inflation this wasn't
mentioned in last year's
briefing um but obviously inflation has
been extremely high it has dropped back
now but the effect of that inflation so
6% W salary increases this year that is
going to be the effect of that is
ongoing it's not just for one year that
will that that effect continues
inflation is falling um but it has had a
very diff you know a major impact on
where we are at the moment um and as it
says inflation makes it more difficult
to budget longer term with any degree of
uncertainty I mean that's just where we
are really um and then
the additionally this time in the in
that report um there's a report giving
some information about information
Communications Technologies
ICT and I'll just mention in this
um that there is a real risk of attack
on District Council
systems um the
council again has in the region of 1200
attempted hacks every week every week a
couple of weeks ago there was um an
attempt by someone an organization in
China we assume we assume yes so these
attacks are very real um in 20 January
2021 Gloucester City Council was subject
to an attack um somebody opened an email
inadvertently and it rendered almost
every system in the council
more about what the ICT units do um I
had a very very good briefing from the
couple of members of the team um couple
of months ago I'd be very happy to
arrange a member briefing on from those
staff if that would be at all helpful so
those are the key variances if you like
on that briefing note I'll turn now to
the written
questions um an apologies if I should
have uh Circ ated these so the written
questions first one was the geographical
information system what is the present
scope of the gis system and what is
presently being developed so the gis is
a corporate database of spatial layers
used across the council for many
purposes including such items as
planning constraints and for land charge
returns updates to these spatial layers
is an ongoing daily weekly task as
required and council is currently
developing a new GIS viewer software
application for use by all staff that
have a GIS requirement this will replace
the current version and it will allow
analysis of spatial locations pan Zoom
measuring tools for lengths areas Etc
and includes address
searching and by developing this product
inhouse uh it means that we can provide
geographical information system
capabilities across the council with
without any license fees associated with
a third party product and there may be a
question about license fees later on we
also continue to maintain and update the
public mapping tool used to present the
South warshire local plan under
development and again this has been
developed inhouse for both for the
benefit of both Stratford and War policy
officers and all residents and
interested
parties also in the pipeline is the new
grounds maintenance contract due to come
into effect in April 2024 and for this
the gis team are also providing all
spatial data requirements so there's a
lot of work going on inhouse there
um the question two the parish and town
websites how much does SDC charge parish
and town councils for providing their
websites and how many parish councils
are using this
service um this is a service we've
offered for many years initiated
originally by national awards for all
funding and there is periodic interest
from Parish Town councils wishing to
have either a new website or to refresh
their existing site it's not something
we actively promote but we do take on
projects when requested if it can be
accommodated within other projects and
development costs can range from 700 to
over ,000 but it is dependent on the
parish council Town council's
requirements for their websites most
recent refresh was for olster Town
Council for cost of
£700 ongoing costs of Parish Council
Parish Town Council websites including
hosting domain name and support costs
are in the range of 235 to
365 per year and currently we have eight
Parish Council Town Council websites in
total we've recently taken over the
running of the Shakespeare birthday
celebrations website the external cost
of this was 35,000 a year and this is
now undertaken inhouse for Less 50 so by
bringing things inhouse it really is
very very cost
effective which sort of links to the
next question was SDC software for other
authorities what software is being
developed by SDC for other
authorities so we tend to develop
software for District Council St for
District Council and if there is
interest from other local authorities
make a charge for its use which recovers
part of the in-house development costs
the exception to this was
anot booking system developed
specifically for churwell and North an
when we were part of the three-way
partnership for the support of this
system CH will pay 1 12200 a year XV the
only other software we're currently
developing for another authorities use
is the Freedom of Information System a
copy was given I bu button a copy was
given to WDC when we were in shared
service and this will be Main maintained
and updated for both authorities further
updates for war will be subject to a
legal agreement currently being put
together that specifies that war agrees
to pay 50% of ongoing development costs
this is yet to be formally agreed by
WDC and just a sort of footnote to that
um there are some small commercial
opportunities within ICT aren't there
Richard that that can be looked
at if you want to comment on that sorry
you've got to got to be careful with
commercial opportunities because we can
develop stuff we have worked with stra
District Council in the past with our
timekeeping system but what you don't
want to do is um commit the authority to
ongoing support that you may or may not
be able to deliver so you don't want to
enter into a contract that somebody then
comes back and holds you to and ends up
costing us money so we're quite careful
to try and recover development costs to
make it cheaper for us us but we're not
necessarily in it to make a longterm
return if that makes sense thank you um
and the fourth question are you happy
with Ernst young as Auditors now I
looked back as I'm sure you all have on
the questions on the 3D of February last
year because there is relevance I if you
if you'll bear with me I'd like to just
um read a little bit from and this is
probably my previous
um councelor Harvey repli um the
question was external audit this is last
year it appears that external audit have
capacity issues costs have increased
significant have increased significantly
can we make
representations councilor Harvey's reply
which which is relevant today um
external audit has been too cheap for a
number of years the consequence of this
has meant that the audit provider has
not been able to recruit qualified staff
to undertake the audits with the budgets
they have been provided with as a
consequence many of the staff that
arrive to undertake the audits of
trainees audits take longer and all
queries and decisions are referred up
the chain of command for authorized
answers inevitably this adds time and
cost the section1 officer has made
representations asking for a more
realistic charge to enable the audit
firm to adequately resource the team
so coming forward to today um so the
question was are we happy with Ernst and
Young as
Auditors Ern and young were appointed
through the public sector audit
appointments the psaa agreement and they
were appointed at a time when prices
were very competitive and one with a low
bid ASE previously referred since then
the market has changed and Auditors have
been leaving the local Authority sector
and leaving the firms to un undertaking
the audits as a consequence this
shortage has resulted in higher salary
demands from those still working in the
sector as the audits have progressed
each year it's become more apparent that
more junior staff have Beena engaged to
undertake the initial audit work and any
queries they or the council have have
been passed up the chain of command to
the more experienced auditor which in
itself has created delays and costs in
addition where we' have seen technical
issues surrounding infrastructure assets
for example Ernst and Young have been
less inclined to resolve issues with
their own
interpretation whereas other audit firms
have pushed on with decisions and this
infrastructure assets that's been
something that has affected a number of
councils isn't it Richard so this isn't
just something that affects this Council
it's across the
sector this may be due to the nature of
eron Young's culture where they are less
inclined to take risk but it does mean
it keeps the technical assessment of the
audit open and therefore acing costs
whatever the reason additional costs
have been experienced and delays that
have then impacted on authorities as
workloads concertina into Times of year
where the council would be expecting to
undertake other work nationally the
whole audit issue is having a massive
impact on the government's ability to
rely on the financial information coming
from local authorities with currently
nearly a thousand audits
outstanding
um we're happy within that context with
ER than young and satisfied they've
undertaken the best audit they can with
the resources they have available as
from 20 Richie can you 23 24 as from 23
24 we do have new Auditors AET AET um
the price of the audit has increased
accordingly um for 2020
20221 it was
49,000 45
45 that's what they were told they
that's the amount they audit firm were
told they would have for the basic audit
so that's what they were and that has
increased to
139,000 Curren that's right
yeah so
and it's going to cost
139,000 that would be basic we've put
we've we' had this discussion about a
year ago at uh I think it was overview
and scrutiny no it's audit Comm
committee and we were warned it would go
up by 150% so I did put in the budget
175,000 for external audit it's coming
just short of 140 ,000 but that is for
the base audit so inevitably they do a
deep dive in a particular area of
concern does come out slightly higher
normally than the base audit
so but again Richard can confirm my
understanding is that this is without
the control of the council we have no
control over the Auditors are appointed
externally I I remember being on the
committee last year when this came up
and we quered it vigorous
it's been through a framework agreement
it's been correctly tendered the
Market's completely changed the people
have moved out and
uh yeah whil I advocated a small
increase so they could uh afford better
caliber of staff I wasn't quite
expecting such an increase but yeah can
I just come in on that one it's quite
interesting um
certainly chaines have always been used
in in the process of accountancy an AIT
going back to my times when I first
started in the local government in the
late 80s um I think some of the times
now they've become more risk averse uh
and want to dot their eyes and cross
every te so they don't have any
potential liabilities CU some some big
um accountancy firms have received quite
a bit of criticism when certain big
organizations have failed and we can all
Quote several different ones so I think
they seem to becom in Risk averse my
concerns always been at the time is the
amount of detail we have to produce in
the accounts in local government because
it came from a move and I can't remember
whichever government it was I you know
and I won't comment but it tended to be
they tend wanted to change local
government accounts public sector
accounts become quite similar to the
private sector accounts which I never
agreed with and we produced so many
pages of accounts that
probably we could count on several HS
the amount of members of the public
actually look at and read and digest you
could probably say the same in in
private sector organizations you know
the shareholders how many look at the
accounts but we're having to produce a
statement of accounts that nobody really
looks at very few residents get any
benefit from it and it's costing us a
lot of money you know all of the sudden
we're talking well into six figures
nearly 200,000 ballet on the cost to
come out and that is something that is
quite frustrating but I know you got
very little control over that but
whether whe there sometimes and you know
perhaps a a different government might
change it but I would very much doubt it
in the same way we're going to have
longer yeah more one year settlements I
can't imagine that changing quickly I
think I got other things i' be
concentrating on as the next local
government off myself also we tended to
be lower at the lower end of priorities
shall we say um so yeah I think that is
really frustrating but I can understand
the reasons behind some of these
increases but it's not really serving
the residents of strapford District
these additional costs we not get any
real benefit from it apart from
insurance that our accounts are are
suitable they they've received an
unqualified opinion
um but this is not unusual the the Del
cuz I know Count's got some issues with
their um with their auditor was in the
Press recently so it is quite
frustrating but yeah it is it's a
difficult one so best of luck with that
can I just I just come back very briefly
if I may CH I think we do need and I
I'll ask Richard to help me out on this
one um or to give additional comment um
I think there there isn't
in obviously as a public facing
organization we do need to be open and
transparent and even if only one member
of the public wants to read the finance
report then it still needs to be
provided and that is again beyond our
control anyway um there is an impact
on um staff time and costs with these
delays in having
the accounts agreed and signed off um
and you know I know Richard has said to
me several times that currently his his
team are juggling with 2021 22 20
multiple years so Richard could you just
give a little bit of a sort of bit more
insight into that the number of years
that you're having to juggle and the
impact on staff time yeah certainly yeah
the um 2020 21 accounts we managed to
get finally signed off on the morning of
the 4th of May this year significant
dates I may remember because we had
delegated authority for the the chair of
audit committee to sign that off and we
didn't know when we'd have another chair
so we wanted to get it signed that day
um so that sort of gives some context as
to when that year was signed off we're
working on the
2122 but as councelor Curtis says I've
got a member of we have lightly resource
I've got a member of Staff that's spend
six months doing final accounts six
months doing budgets
everything's constantiner in in the
government are looking at a way to get
rid to overcome this backlog of nearly a
thousand audits outstanding audits we're
going to hear in December what their
suggestion is and from what has been
said I think what they're going to do is
do a very light touch on all the ones
leading up to
22 23 which is last year then do a sort
of a good audit on that one and move on
from there so just sort of ignore
everything that went before but what
what it will mean is we will probably
get qualified
audits so they'll probably just what I
would imagine they would want to make
sure that our bank Rec reconciliation
has been done then our assets are looked
at very high level just to make sure
that the assets are valued correctly are
in the books correctly and they'll
probably ignore everything else and move
on um but they'll qualify that audit
saying we've done this that and the
other but we haven't checked this so
don't rely on any of the figures
but saying that when they do move on to
the following year uh when they do the
full process usually if there's
something a right it comes out in the
following year anyway so I think that's
what they're thinking is but um I don't
think we're going to get out of it
without a qualified audit 2324 again
should be
unqualified correct yes yeah yeah I've
got um aets the new company that sort of
contacts me say Well when can we get
going I said I don't know because I
don't don't know when it you're going to
finish so because they can't take over
they want to verify the balances brought
forward from the previous audit talked
to the previous Auditors to have a look
to see what they
did I did read this week some people are
predicting this could take up to five
years to correct to bring everyone up to
dat I don't think the government could
live that long without knowing accurate
well with reasonable Assurance what what
the figures they they are using you know
whether they're correct basic
you know you can't make spending
decisions on incomplete
information I think if I can just add
that this this Authority is you know are
by no means alone in in this problem and
it is a national problem and it's not a
problem as I understand anyway from the
conversations I've had with Richard it's
not a problem of our making it's the
problem is exter internal and it is
slowly being resolved is that correct
well it's not being it's it's actually
it's getting worse but they're looking
to resolve it but it's certainly
impacting on our work I'm looking now to
I'm going to have to recruit someone
temporarily to catch up basically
because I can see what's going to happen
they're going to say we want this this
year done that year done this year done
by this date and I'm well actively
recruiting today looking for a temporary
position because when that report comes
out in December toward the end of
December we're expecting it everybody's
going to be looking for additional
resources so the cost of that's going to
go up as well so whatever happens this
is going to cost us
more oh go councel Wy hoggins wants to
come in please R indeed talking about
Finance but what have we done as a
council then this is the senior officers
in the room what have we done to the
count as as a council to sort of say you
know this isn't this is a really
intolerable situation because reading
between the lines if you're doing audits
with forgive me if I'm being
spectacularly dim it's rare indeed I
know but um five years hence going back
all of that time to catch up key members
of staff that were involved in the audit
in in in in uh in the finance will have
left anywhere there's there just can't
be any accountability for what's for
what could be for what could be found if
you're going to be playing a a catch up
to to that level and we all know that
some councils in that meantime are going
to collapse anywhere because they
haven't got um the money there so really
this is this there's only one winner out
of this and that is external um
providers of an of of the auditing
systems that's that's auditing companies
that are coming into Council you know
that's that's that can't be right
because this is becoming more of a
hindrance of running councils
efficiently and effectively so what have
we done to sort of um bring you know the
government up to you know to seek a
solution to to
this well certainly we we've gone back
to our Auditors on a regular basis uh
the problem with Ernst and Young for us
is they also do National Health audits
that are also very strict in their
timing so for
example was it last year we were sort of
trotting through the audit and it got to
sort of the end of March and they
disappeared and they reappeared at the
end of June and they just
literally went off and did the NHS
Audits and then then we were sort of
half half the questions that were half
answered were answered at the end of
June and carried on again so it's it's
a it's it's a known problem we would
just be reitera we we haven't contacted
the government they're well aware of
what the problems are and and it like
it's been said it's every
Authority um um I think the only option
is to do a quick fix to bring everybody
up to date just for the very reason you
said because there won't be any
accountability people would have gone um
the longer it goes on the bigger the
problems will build up underneath whilst
these things aren't being looked at I
think they just need to be brought up to
date everyone needs to take that hit of
the qualified audit and just say look
we've done the last ones good the two
years before May be questionable but
let's move on I think that's the only
way
forward can I just make a comment there
chair um I think councelor W hoggins and
I were both on the excellent training
session the other day on report Reading
as well as writing and there was a
comment made on that from thork local
Authority I believe it
was where the members did not like the
information that the section1 officer
was bringing to
them and as a result of ignoring this
information or sending it back saying no
we don't want to read that report thank
you very much um thork have they had
section 114 yes so ended up th with a
section 114 notice what I would reassure
this committee is that I don't think
there is any chance that Mr B
would yield to any sort of pressure
about
presenting reports that we didn't really
want to see I have every confidence that
he would say to me councelor Curtis this
is the information I'm presenting and I
expect it to go forward so I I have
absolute
confidence in in the finance team to
ensure that we
are taking to
fin follow yep I do however recognize
the stress this is causing uh you
Richard because and and your whole team
because this is quite an intolerable
situation that you just can't you just
sort of it's like seaweed just pulling
you down the whole time as you try to
sort of swim forwards this is you know
that's that's quite that's quite
worrying and that needs to be part of a
risk it it is it is stressful though
isn't it it's you know and having to
recruit extra members of Staff just to
just to tread water really that's that's
not good are you on about the situation
with the the audits or dealing with
councelor Curtis coun could could
possibly
comment yeah sorry then David I know you
find out quite
um I I'll raise a few questions if
people don't mind are you happy yeah um
we've talked about section 114 and I I I
found an article that cancer Junior was
coted it and I think she said I think
straford is in a better position the the
most um which is was good to hear
especially when you keep on hearing this
section 114 notices um one of the
reasons for that I believe was that Mr
borrow
injunction with with cers set up the
inflation and volatility Reserve which
was well into seven figures I believe I
can't remember which exactly be
interesting to see how much of that's
been used because I know that councelor
ciry said about where because of the
one-year settlements we're having to put
more money aside in terms of risk and
volatility Etc and that money could be
potentially used for on the Cal tax you
know for providing Services one of the
any positive sides of that with having
the high amount of reserves uh available
is that can be invested on the money
market at a higher price and I believe I
think we earned again well into 7
figures um that enabled the last year's
accounts to be relatively close to being
being
balanced so slight statement there which
I think was which is nodding which is a
good sign that I'm not talking too much
nonsense um it's just this inflation
Reserve how are we doing with that is
not to be re
re needed or how much we like like to be
like to be used in the next next next 12
months should I go first um thanks the
the inflation Reserve budgeted for
2425 is 1 a half million which is an
increase of half million over pre over
24 it is a reserve I think given as I
alluded to earlier on the volatility of
the world right now I think it's prudent
um however it is a reserve if as we move
through the year inflation
Falls and Richard considers that some of
that Reserve can be released to provide
additional Services then that's
something that we would
revisit I but I I would agree that at
the moment given where we are inflation
is falling but it could go back up there
could be an escalation of the war in the
Middle East which could push oil prices
through the ceiling so I I would agree
with Richard it's a prudent thing to do
at the moment but it is a reserve it can
fall in but Richard you may want to add
to
that yeah I just add a small small
amount to it that that Reserve was
created at a time when inflation was
increasing at an unknown rate um the the
medium-term financial strategy that was
created at the time I put in 4% pay
award for example
now that that that was an estimate
um when you do a medium-term financial
strategy that's over five years if
you're too aggressive at the start with
your inflation assumptions that becomes
baked in and it sort of multiplies five
times across the the duration of the
medium-term financial strategy and you
can quite easily
end up having to make savings that you
don't necessarily have to because you've
been too pessimistic with your
assumptions so what I was happy to do
was create a reserve of one and a half
million for this financial year budget
at 4% as it happens salaries came in
higher at 6% so that was a two 2%
pressure on a 13 million pound budget
was 260,000
which ordinarily I would have dipped
into that Reserve to cover but as uh C
the Crump has identified we've achieved
additional investment Returns on the
money that we're holding so we've been
fortuit us that we've had money on
deposit so as inflation has stayed High
Investments have remained High that's
paid for the additional costs that we've
incurred during that time so we haven't
had to draw on it as cancel has said
if should we have an election and post
that election inflation continues to
drop I'm quite happy to reduce that
reserve and and to release that money
for for whatever is needed for so we're
not going to it's not something that
will be held
indefinitely the business rates
Equalization Reserve has been created
from receipts from business rates over
what was budgeted and it's sort of put
to one side so you sort of taking the
Peaks off to fill in the trough later on
in the medium-term financial strategy
and the current medium-term fin
Financial strategy uses just under3
million pounds in the fifth year to make
the whole strategy sustainable
basically
um the reason for that is that we don't
know what the the funding settlements
are so we've been well I've been
cautious in my assumptions in years
three four and five and because of that
caution I've needed to use that ear Mar
Reserve if they gave us a three-year
settlement we know what we're working
with for three years we wouldn't need
such a large Reserve because we know
what funding we would receive so as long
as we continue to receive onee
settlements we're not unique War have
done just to saying that their res
significantly higher than ours but
um yeah that's that's the only way we
can manage our finances and make sure
that we're not having to make knee-jerk
reactions if we didn't have that as a
buffer you may get to the end of a year
and think kri we need to make a huge
amount of savings next year we've got to
save one and a half mil what what are we
going to do but at least that having
that Reserve will give us time to plan
properly and with sort of con considered
decisions say Obviously um shall I can
on with the questions so members
happy good good and I like the fact that
Mr borrow keeps on agreeing with me and
I've got he to notice that about four
times in the um yeah the next point I
think we've we've touched on you know
the challenging times ahead inflation
lots of unknowns Etc um and the reasons
we've done these things and how inv
valuable inflation Reserve is is proven
and and that so I think that's important
and again we touched on the budget uh
task and finish group on the budget
which everybody wants to join which is
is is amazing there's going to be
another one as well that we'll
eventually find out um so I think think
that's really
positive um my point these are all going
to be linked I think eventually um we've
had um last week or the week before uh
the notice about the data breach um
that's com and I appreciate there will
be ongoing investigations both
internally and potentially VI the police
so I I fully accept that we won't be
able to go into too much detail about
this so we've had that so be interested
to see what cost there will be um both
in terms of reputational damage and both
in terms of criminal costs and in terms
of uh any fines we we may occur but what
I'm asking from from yourselves would be
once everything was clear once
everything was finished we would
potentially lock a report back to a
audit AUD exting probably auditing
standards as well for K the yeah k I
told me to sell that as well so uh two
for the price of one value for money
there um so that would be interesting
toer about things like that and then
we've also
had uh an urgent decision regarding the
licenses on on Microsoft so again all
you know it linked so again it'd be
interesting to see the reasons the
internal processes around that and whe
the internal audit as part of their
internal process review needs to look at
it and will that be part of the whole
thing so that's sort of all linked into
terms of internal audit internal
processes and making sure we've got
enough resources and we've got the
resilience to do that and I appreciate
councelor Curtis spoke about um the
hacking and that Council which I can't
remember now um GL that was I was going
say stray but Richard mentioned stayed
with something else I weren't too far
away so I think there
are I would like some reassurance not
now but a future meeting that we are
we've got enough resources to do the job
interestes in the reasons for the causes
what can we do any damage both internal
um both reputationally and in terms of
costs Etc and do we need to ensure we
using our internal audit resources
properly to make sure we've got the
right processes in place and things
don't get missed so slightly long-winded
question all interl don't expect an
answer now really but just some
reassurance
please thank you chair so on the first
point of the DAT data breach um there
are ongoing internal and police
investigations uh I'm sure in due course
of report would be published but at this
stage I can't offer any further comment
and I'm sure the committee would
understand that if there are ongoing
investigations it wouldn't be prudent
for me to say anything further at this
stage um but I'm sure yes a report an
invest once the com investigations have
been completed a report would be
appropriate um regarding the Microsoft
license um I think I this is a an annual
or tri-annual license renewal Microsoft
licenses are incredibly expensive um but
I'm sure Mr B would like to give a
little bit more information on
this yes thank you uh thank you
councelor Curtis this um three years ago
the council went through a ways of
working exercise and it was just pre the
uh pandemic the covid pandemic and um it
was then it was decided that uh Office
365 was the the way forward and the
teams meeting and the systems that we
have today uh that license came up for
Renewal
um uh because of the value of that over
the three years it required an internal
um key decision to be recorded and we we
didn't have it at that value from the
original submission so it needed to be
done again it's an oversight that we we
need to sort of make a process put a
process in place it doesn't happen again
the actual procurement side has been
done absolutely fine it's just making
sure that that um key decision is
recorded which is now been
done um it's just yeah it's just the
value of it
exceeded what would otherwise normally
be allowed to sort of
render it's it's 390,000 over over over
three years isn't it
it's less than that but we haven't
signed the contract so we're not going
to quote the exact figure but I think
the the the
slight we're not saying any figures
because the
contract a reasonable
amount so the the over it's over the
threshold that where a key decision is
required which is but the the the annual
figure is below I think that's where
slight confusion AR the the annual
amount is below the key to ision but
when it's aggregated over three years it
exceeds it so yeah so I think long say
I'd heard the procurement process was
was fine uh which is reassuring um again
it's just about internal process and
making sure we talked about transparency
haven't we earlier so we need to be
above board uh and again just the my
final point was about internal audit do
we need to look at this area I know they
do look at various systems Etc on a
regular basis is there some area work we
need to guide them on to making sure
that everybody's the reassurance about
it or do we need to wait until the
internal audit process the internal
process on the data breach Etc and any
criminal investigation comes out and
then we can then make some decisions on
that um I'm due to meet with the uh
internal audit uh provider who we we buy
that service in from the County Council
um in January so we'll be scoping out
the audit plan for the next financial
year year there will be uh standard
things that are covered based on risk um
they'll be covered anyway but there are
spare days within the plan that could be
used U following any outcome and I think
the timing would be probably be be about
right uh to include something within
that F you next year's audit
program so
yes have we got any other
questions
can the Wally hoggins just to get back
to it I raised the point a while ago
about devices to help us to go paper
free have we have we got any further
forward that at all please and also to
note that yesterday OPEC announced they
were cutting back on oil production uh
to protect the price of oil and if the
price of oil goes up which it inevitably
will that will have could potentially
have a quite a bad effect on inflation
and that's completely Beyond anybody
else's control in this room uh yes it
for paper
free absolutely this
is I haven't it hasn't gone away a lot
of work's been done in in the background
of that what councelor war hogins was
asking for was a device where you could
read everything paper free mark up
highlight things um an example of one
was given um we were promised one on
loan from a neighboring Authority that
hasn't been forthcoming despite several
requests for it so we're looking for
sources of other devices the problem
is as counselors you you get sent
documents in different formats and a lot
of these devices are specifically
designed for say PDFs uh but you may get
sent an Excel document or you may get
sent a Word document that you want to
mark up and it's making
sure that it syncs that it uploads this
information very EAS leag so what we
don't want to do is have to train
everybody in uploading documents to a
separate device or having docking
facilities in the rest of it so we we're
just making sure that um you you're
looking so you don't believe me but the
device that the device that you
suggested only operated effectively with
a PDS and and it wasn't clear how it
would work easily with other documents
that that was the concern that we had we
couldn't get our hands on one to test
test it but
um I just thought we were just going to
go and buy a couple to sort of have a
look at really I thought that was a
conversation not borrowing them from
different authorities I I just don't you
know um anyway never mind it's clearly
it's a it's not going to happen is it so
thanks thanks so well we're continuing
to look at it no it's a serious thing
that you know an awful lot of papers
produced I I try and avoid paper and
I've got the the agenda on my screen
it's a touchcreen the these laptops are
due to be refreshed shortly so uh it's
something that needs to be decided upon
before these laptops are refresh because
you don't want to be buying laptops
because these are about ,000 pounds each
as well as another device okay sorry
about that then so what about just you
know I hate to say the Apple word but
you know the the the Apple Pro you know
um just the the uh like iPads really
would that be not be more efficient to
be greener and and so forth again it's
having the software on there that will
run and getting Apple to talk the
trouble is we're committed to Microsoft
which is why we're buying Office 365
devices I'm aware of of a personal
friend that has a a business and he
likes apple and he has everything Apple
but he has to have a laptop by the side
of him to buy his post office franking
stuff because Apple won't communicate
for whatever reason with with this the
software okay that the post office uses
so unfortunately Apple are happy in
apple land but they're not happy to come
out of it and we for the council
Microsoft Works 95% 99% of the time for
what we need it to do so unfortunately
when you start mix mixing operating
systems and platforms it doesn't usually
end very
well the cat terminals I'm sure you're
aware of that we're looking to um re
state in in some
locations that we'll use a hopefully
we'll use a um
Samson based non-apple device because it
it just interacts a lot easier with our
current
systems thanks very much for that detail
thank
you I say so the the moral of the story
is that you can use Apple for for your
core work but
that so sorry that was a a brief yeah so
um on pap County we use the Sur Pros
there and and not don't have to carry
own things like this you portone is is
really useful so yeah I think it's
something we we need to look out
definitely um I can't see any other
questions I know that you really enjoyed
that last pun about Apple
um yeah there must be some comments
about Pips and things like that
um so any other questions and I think we
can let councelor Curtis and Mr Boral go
if
happy um but what we'll need to do now
before we move to the next item on the
agenda been we've been going two and 34
hours just over uh we need to vote to
continue the meeting
[Music]
um past the three hours I think we won't
be too long past the 3 hours but I think
we were going to have to because we've
got the cabinet meeting papers the
annual work
program uh the work plan to consider um
I'm more than willing to carry on if if
members are uh I think it makes sense um
catch the Ral please um I'm really sorry
I have to go just after 1 o' yeah I'm so
sorry so how many do we need to be
C MERS yeah yeah okay that that's fine
if if we can keep a minimum of three m
members here which I will be one of them
um I'm willing to carry on so um can we
have a vote for that on the provisor
that the people have to go go and then
they're willing to let the the people
who are able to stay carry on with the
meeting so we all those in favor of that
is that fair great thank
you we will there's
another there another minutes F so so I
will be um yeah the next item is the
cabinet meeting on the 4th of December
so we've got our wonderful pieces of
paper that if obviously if it
was
yeah yeah my uh my poster said to me I
do them with a bigger letter
box so
um could
who wants us kick off on this one
then okay we'll start off with Mr Kord I
believe you're there we are he's not in
the old traffic Cricket Grand today he's
he's somewhere Bri
holiday I'm I'm not unfortunately I'm
I'm just at home I'm trying to get rid
of a bit of cold I've got so I didn't
think I'd come to the
office no very
sensible
so yeah this was do you want to give us
a brief introduction John because
obviously it was going to Cabinet the
previous meeting um and then we had our
concerns that were raised at last osc um
and it had to be uh looked at again and
then tweaked and amended you just give
some details of the tweakings and and
how satisfied are the pro how how robust
the process is now and whe there needs
to be some ongoing tweaks Etc and
process
please yes sure thank you um so firstly
want to apologize to members that uh we
needed to uh revisit uh the piece of
work following the um the issues that
osc identified um one might say that's
the uh the the purpose and benefit of of
scrutiny is to to flag these sort of
things up but uh no we we should have
been on on top of that uh in advance so
I you I do apologize for for uh for the
erors there um but what you've got again
is um it's essentially the the the same
principle of the paper which is um
setting out um how we should spend our
our seal monies um what we have done is
um following the the issues um you
identified last time we have gone back
through uh all the uh project
submissions uh and to ensure that we've
been consistent and uh we we did spot uh
some areas where there were some
inconsistencies and uh what you should
have in your agenda papers is
essentially a track changes version of
the um uh the
spreadsheet um that shows where those
changes have occurred um now in light of
those changes it has affected the um the
scoring assessments um so we are
proposing uh different projects in which
to fund uh in accordance with those new
assessments um and what you've also got
now is or cabinet rather have a choice
in some respects about how the the last
charge of that funding uh needs to be
spent um you have a proposal to uh carry
forward uh funds that we have already
collected um just to bear in mind
that uh we we're always running a year
behind with with seal funding so uh the
the funding this is relating to is um
from uh
22 to 31st March 23
primarily and then what we're suggesting
is that there is a a large amount of
funding that we've uh received from 1 of
April this year uh and we could utilize
that um in order to uh fund that and I
think it follows on from a point that Mr
Burl WR made about is better to um spend
the money in our accounts rather than
have it having it sitting there so
that's one of the recommendations is to
carry forward that money that's already
in our accounts so we're not borrowing
or anything like that it's already in
our account but we're looking to spend
it uh sooner rather than later and
you've got the recommendations there to
um uh to do that and to spend it
accordingly um I think um as I said last
time I think um the um portfolio holder
Council C is Keen to revisit um the uh
the mechanism we use for spending seal
um and I I suppose in a way this the
issues we've had this time per
highlights some of that in that it is
quite subjective um we've tried to
objectify as far as possible but um
without going down a very
complicated um route for um assessing
projects take into the um shared
Prosperity fund that's had a lot of work
be behind the scenes on it where you're
scoring outcomes and requires the biders
to um really grasp grasp that uh we are
using quite a simple assessment Matrix
um as I said Council of cure is Keen
that we move away from that so um I I
think you say this this probably
highlights um some many concerns around
why it's probably uh timely to to to
move away to um an alternative approach
really um but I think I've probably
covered them you've got the
recommendations on the front of the
paper um and there is say a choice to be
made um as listed in table four I think
of the um of the paper uh which
additional projects you you may want to
spend because unfortunately we we can't
we can't fund all of the uh worthwhile
projects um on the list but happy to
take any questions thank you can off me
thank you John thank you um yeah thank
you
um obviously I can't talk about one of
them but I see that um and interesting
enough uh Tony perks and I were about
two three hours ago talking about this
very thing about statford porn a rugby
club new Clubhouse and 4G playing pitch
that's now scored 10 instead of
eight uh but I I'm a little bit wory
about that because that is absolutely
dependent on a successful planning
application isn't it it's an enabling
planning application is that right Tony
it is isn't it yeah yeah yes that's
correct cancor off yeah so so I
mean is is it is it okay to to leave it
there knowing that it is dependent on a
planning
application is what I'm trying to
say um I I think it
it could be acknowledging that that um
that that is the case I I think if it
were to be if it scored any higher then
I I think you'd question its
deliverability and I suppose this is the
uh perhaps the uh issues with some of
the scoring is that there's no real
waiting to those criteria I suppose um
and that's what we do need to address in
a wider piece of thinking how we How We
Do allocate money as um accordingly um
but I think it's it's probably been
scored appropriately in terms of its
deliverability but some of the other
benefits it's bringing sort of bring it
up to the top of the pile really um and
that's true for for all of these
projects where it may be that there's a
certain feature of the project that is
really ticking one of the
boxes and you know it's how much weight
you give that in in the current
methodology it's it's getting almost
full weight and what we need to do
therefore if it is integral to the bid
being successful we do need to ensure
that it's delivered as part of the
project it's not one of those things
that they that the the applicant then
turns we don't want to do that anymore
if it was integral to the success so I
think yeah there it has highlighted some
um some issues with with the scoring
mechanism that I say we we are looking
to to address moving forwards
thank you just a follow up if May so if
I'm reading this right in my little
simple head here um previously we chose
three projects that that that scored
highly enough to be selected if you like
but now we're in a situation where there
are eight projects two are clearly ahead
of the other
six um and
am I right in thinking we have to choose
one more from those six projects that
all scored 10 is that is that right do
we have to recommend one more sorry I'm
I yeah I just in my simple head I just
need clarification perks please should I
joh do
you
you well I was just going to say so um
it it just so happens that the scoring
um
um has come out as it has before it was
a very neat fit where I think um the
three the three highest projects and I
can't recall what they scored but the
three highest projects uh sort of
broadly matched the the amount of
funding now what we've got here is a
position where uh the two highest
projects uh meet the amount of funding
there's a fairly significant underspend
and what we're recommending is that then
if you then take into that sort of
second tier the all those projects that
score 10 unfortunately we still can't
fund all of them so you do have some
choices and they're they're the choices
to make in table four essentially and
what we're saying is that if you did
want to uh choose any of the projects at
score
10 uh We've set out some recommendations
for for doing that you may conclude
councilors that you you your
recommendation is only to score to fund
the the top two projects and there
there'll be then some carry forward to
to next year but it it just so happens
that the scoring this time has resulted
in in those eight projects uh coming
forward and um you know you you have got
a choice in respect of which projects to
score 10 you want to score Tony I don't
if you want to add anything to that um
yeah if if I can I think it would be a
couple of points um I think it's worth
just going back on the um the foundation
of s and why it exists it comes out as a
result of of changes to the sort of
section 106 infrastructure of old where
we used to collect section 106 money to
fund
infrastructure um when s came in section
106 used was restricted to sort of
infrastructure that was sort of built
within the development and the seill
collection was allowed for The Wider
infrastructure um that's the reason why
we were sort of recommending that the
statford hospital project sort of is is
taken forward because we consider that's
the type of infrastructure that s was
designed to produce and it's one of the
sort of the key ways that development
sort of pays for healthc care so that we
felt set it aside from some of the other
projects that scored 10 which is why
that one's got a specific
recommendation um turning to councelor
ral's point
specifically
um we have the ability as a council to
bring forward the funding that we
already hold so we can fund some of the
projects on that list I've explained
sort of why we've recommended the the
hospital you could fund the two higher
scoring projects the hospital and there
is the option to spend some all of the
remaining money to sort of going going
down the sort of um the the projects
that scored 10 in terms of the role of
the Oban scrutiny committee this morning
you don't have to make a recommendation
at all you're here to sort of scrutinize
the report to Cabinet if you're happy
with it to go as it is you're not
obliged to say anything but if there's
anything that you want the cabinet to
consider as part of their deliberations
um this is your chance through the
chairman who will be sort of
representing you at the cabinet on on
Monday so yeah you won't be asked to
make a recommendation today unless you
want to but if as a committee you can
agree on something that you all want to
say that can be considered as part of
the decision- making by the
cabinet right CH we're sorry to we're in
a situation where I have to go and uh we
will not be cor yeah I think we will
still say the of the committee there 11
MERS no it's if we if we both go we will
not be
quar it's four
yeah right okay I'm really sorry y yep
no problem it's it's just uh don't to
stayle debate yeah I think there's some
good points again from from Mr Perks I
think
that gr I I'll come I'll sum up at the
end so we'll go for councel Wally
hoggins councelor rice then counc
passenger
sorry sorry
sorry it comes out to a point that I
raised before that when you look at
this and the projects that have been
there is the is where the applications
are for these projects really so
um I'm I'm I'm pretty sure that my
colleagues sat next to me will also be
raising this point that the areas with
the most uh well the biggest badges for
urance are not necessarily going to be
the recipients of some of the larger
sill Awards here which is making me
slightly well sad for our residents
really in the in the South uh unless I'm
reading this very wrong but I I do think
that in future it would be really useful
and perhaps um solitary to look at a map
with these things pinpointed on because
what it could come down to is people's
ability to fill out forms and to see
adverts going out to say please apply
for sill monies sorry I know Tony perks
I'm getting that look from you so do do
interject thank
you I think that's a little bit of a
binary view um in my introduction I sort
of said that s was to provide
infrastructure to offset the effects of
development now the local infrastructure
for that that's within the site is still
covered by section 6 sill is to fund the
more Regional infrastructure that does
that and people do tend to travel to of
the larger conations for things like
hospitals um and in the South we have
quite a significant s payment currently
sort of going into the shipston I know
that's a controversial topic but in
terms of last year when that was applied
for that there has been money gone there
I think it would be it's not for me to
sort of say how how you interpret things
but unusual if it was sort of divided up
geographically it needs to be divided
upon sort of need and the type of
project um and and I think over a number
of years um projects have been allocated
in different parts of the district it is
I take your point quite a statford
Centric proposal proposal this year but
a large part of that is is coming from
the from the hospital which do serve the
whole District if that's any help I just
intergen got to say even more it's
almost looking at this is could be
interpreted now that there is some
political bias to this this the
uh allocations here however the other
matter that I wanted to ask was um to Mr
careford is how are we going to prevent
the dearle of the last set of papers
coming to overview and scrutiny with the
errors that are on them have have we
established a checking process now to
make sure that we don't have that
scenario repeating itself thank
you yes I mean just to ask that second
Point yes uh there is a process when we
now need
following uh that you we should have
gone through uh before um I I think the
other point that I wanted to make is
that I think um if we do change the
system um and this will address your
first point Council that um by relating
it more to where the development is is
coming from and and also that strategic
perspective as opposed to the more local
uh needs I you you'll get
um uh a much clearer idea and
understanding of where and how still
should be spent I think the two things
together uh should resolve uh the
problems we've had
recently C the passing G then cancel the
rice oh so I got distracted can the rice
and can of passingham both
interchangeable
both uh yes I I'd just like to to to to
comment that the scoring system the more
I think about it uh the more inadequate
it appears to be I really don't
understand um how we've arrived at at
this but I'm sure probably we would have
arrived at the same place if we'd had a
slightly different scoring system but my
question is this um and it's probably my
ignorance but uh I'm curious to know
what happens to the projects that are
unsuccessful do they just roll over to
next year or do do those people who've
applied have to reapply if those
projects are still um well of needed by
um by that um that area um and the
second question I have and it's a purely
mathematical one is and it comes back to
this wretched scoring system
there are a couple of items that are
quite
tiny um but only scored uh nine uh The
rattley Village Hall roof and uh
resurfacing Stratford Greenway and I'm
just curious why given that the
carryover is at least £43,000 and goes
up to7 sorry 266,000 if none of them are
chosen why these two tiddlers couldn't
just be added into the uh
list thank
you I think so to answer your first
point councelor so um essentially they
they do carry over we we contact again
the the project uh
applicants um every you every year and
if there are any updates they can they
can make to those projects but they they
essentially get carried forward so um
yeah it's not a case of um we we we
don't want to fund some of these it's
the case that you know it's it's related
to the amount of funding funding we have
so yeah that in essence they they roll
over um certainly you know the committee
could recommend that actually the the
the carryover is used to fund some of
those smaller projects I think as long
as we've got a a rational and reasonable
basis for um allocating the funds then
you know that that's acceptable um say
we've as officers have used use the the
scoring as a way to
prioritize but if if members were
otherwise minded um I believe that you
know that could be a rational way
forwards thank you the passing gun
please um yeah my question is about the
allocation from last year par the the
one that U to me is outstanding is the
new GP practice uh at the Ellen Badger
Hospital site um which on this schedule
says the legal agreement has not been
signed by the
ICB well I checked this up last month
when when exactly the same entry was
made uh with with the um seal officer
who said that the this 518,000 had just
been drawn down by um by the
ICB um and I quered this
because uh the GP practice in
shipston uh is still saying that they
don't they either can't or they um they
can't afford to move into the new site
and um no there's been no Public
Announcement from anybody that the GB
practice is going to move into the new
site and so my question one is has this
money really been has this agreement
been signed and the money drawn down and
uh if the current GP practice has not
move agreed to move in there what is
going to happen to whatever it is
they're building for GPS there will it
be a white
elephant Mr Perks yeah yeah um following
the last meeting we conted Simon doble
who's the um lead at the ICB sort of on
this project and i' I've got an email
back from him now we asked him whether
they were going to sort of committing to
spending the money or whether we could
put it back into the pot was essentially
what we were asked to sort of take up
with him last time his email says I'll
read it just so as you clear what it
says exactly to hi David which is David
Buckland in this instance to confirm the
practice are still intending on
utilizing this funding in full the ICB
is working with the practice and Swift
to review options and confirm irm how we
will progress so we've got sort of
Fairly unequivocal um sort of commitment
they're proceeding with the project to
the best of my knowledge the legal
agreement hasn't been signed and the
money hasn't been drawn down oh it
hasn't been drawn no um I I'll clarify
that if you've had different
confirmation from the section 106
officer but my understanding was that
the money is still in our account
waiting for the proposal lead agreement
to be signed but I will clarify that for
you it yeah it just seems not a very
good way to proceed does it that the
whole thing is very chaotic I think yeah
again I think that could again be part
of the process of the review of the
seill yes
um so I think yeah that's a good point
CC B I think we can we can bring that
when I sum up I think we could perhaps
bring that in as part of part of the
review so it's Clarity yeah I was just
wondering could could I have a a
confirmation of that in an email or
something then councelor per I mean
officer pergs what exactly would you
like confirming so I get the right thing
I I just keep hearing different things
and there's a lot of confusion about
what's happening so it'd be nice to see
something in writing that the the ICB
have um uh from the ICB saying exactly
what's happening because people in ship
do want to know I think I very much
doubt I'll be able to provide that to
you um but I will be able to provide
whether the se1 61 has been drawn down
can I just go back to the original
wording of that email that you said
because actually there was there was um
there was an element of doubt in that
email it said in the email I believe if
I'm just remembering this uh correctly
even with my menopause brain that it
said it is the intention of the GP
surgery or the GP practice to still use
this money now can you write back to
that gentleman that wrote you that
letter and reminds him that it is to
develop a new GP practice within the
current Ellen badger Hospital site it is
not just for the GP practice as it is at
the moment to just do with it what they
will because there is an element of
doubt in what he's written there and
it's just a question of nailing him down
just slightly thank you do you get what
I'm saying Tony
thanks yeah I think okay yeah John got
something to say John Mr K sorry thank
you um it was it was just the point that
obviously if
if monies are not spent then we we do
put them back into the part as Mr Perks
alluded to so it could be you know
there's a possibility that you know uh
next time around that if if this money
is still been sting there no legal
agreements been signed we take the view
that actually no that's not satisfactory
and we'll we'll recoup the money and
deallocate it so uh we've done that on
other projects um so it that could be an
outcome here uh but say the at the
moment where we sit now we we were
satisfied that there was a degree of
certainty that um it would come forward
we will keep it under review of
course great thank you for that um can I
just some sum up now um I I think I'm
happy I think from what I'm hearing
that we recommend the first two 12 and
11 but not given any of the
recommendations um
uh and especially there was concerns
about uh the stra I and Rugby Club and
and the planning permission Etc um so
that I I think we're happy I would be
happy if we did that uh about the first
two
points Mr kid spoke about the process
review um and I I think that overing
scrutiny should have some role in it um
in the same way that when we were doing
the Budget Group on task and finish we
were having people from outside over in
scrutiny group um I think you know there
should be input from us um whatever the
cabinet decide and that that could be
got back to C of cure you know
obviously we've had comments from K the
passing G about chaotic Etc and so
there's some clarity around that there
still I think the waiting at the process
requires some more refinement and I'm
sure if councelor keithy was here he
would say exactly the
same again do we need to look at
barriers of Entry to um apply for this
um you know and again just being you
know from the east of the district it
does seem to be you know my residents
could potentially be saying how it's all
being spent in Stratford and I take on
the point about the strapford hospit
hospital a lot of people do go there
even from my part of the the District so
um I can accept some points but
potentially not the others so I think we
need to look at that again to do a
perception whether we do have a map as
part of the process and yeah the final
point is overview and scrutiny to assist
so I think um yeah I think that's
summarized our comments I think that's
relatively accurate I getting some knots
so I'm happy that we we're okay with
that one is that make sense Mr cord
just one final question so how do we
audit or how do we check that you know
they sign all the legal agreements how
do we actually physically check that the
money has and I am thinking of the elen
badger hospital and so forth how do we
um actually check that the money has
been spent on exactly what was promised
and applied for am I have I missed a
document here because that that's my you
know it's a lot of money that we it's a
lot taxpayers money that we're giving to
organizations more or less in good faith
thank you I think part of of review
again that could be teased out and is
I'm sure is been done been done but
again some clarification about that and
again whether we need to put in
different criteria as well um so and
time scales Etc because that's the
problem with yes it is capital money and
then it drags on and then because of
inflation that we've already heard about
in different parts of this meeting the
money that's sent available isn't fit
for purpose to build the original so I
think yeah I think we we again I'm sure
it's been done but if we have some
clarity about that as part of the
process as well I think that will be
fair is that right John we'll um I don't
think you got any other questions and
that
so how's going to have loads of notes
for me that I can read out on Monday
particularly around this one so I think
we've divided that one really well so we
can move on to the next one which is
anybody got any comments to do
with the performance
data
yeah any any real ISS Simon do you want
to come forward and just give us a quick
overview um any major concerns or you
just very brief for a couple of minutes
because I know we're on a tight time
scale and just just give us any of your
concerns and we got any yeah where we
got any real
concerns um if you hav't got any
concerns or what should we be doing
differently should I introduce the
report whilst oh you're on yeah I'm on
now so um yeah basically um there isn't
really any major
um things in there that's uh of any
great uh problem um the main thing to
say with this report is that
um
676 months isn't
it
yeah this will be the last report in its
guys um because obviously the council
plan is changing um next week um so the
the remaining quarter three well sorry
the quarter 2 year three extended
your um plan outstanding projects they
will some of them will be following on
into the next one um that will be worked
on by myself and a colleague and um
obviously the management team to try and
work out which ones will roll over and
obviously they'll go to council for
approval um so the actions for the new
council plan will be worked up in the
next uh few few weeks so on this on the
on the actual um performance
indicators um just well whether any
comments from the uh the the meeting um
of any any great
notes no say haven't got particularly
it's again it's a lot of things um like
can say it's any even though we're near
the end of the the calendar year um must
realized it's it's only two quarters
till the end of September um so we've
still from that point of view we've
still got six months for some of these
things to to be delivered and obviously
that's you know it's that doesn't make
sense um ongoing pending Etc uh it's
part of the report so um I've not got
any real concerns about this I think we
not it we it be interesting to see a the
new format how it comes out and whether
there be some form of like
reconciliation between the changes
between the two or those make it as
fallproof as possible for us counselors
that will be helpful councel the r
please thank you chair um yes my usual
uh comment at this stage um but I note
that there's going to be um uh a draft
communication strategy produced for
cabinet consideration in
January um will that be one of the items
that comes before this Committee in
January do we know want to yeah can do y
good thank you good nice easy question
thank you that may not be January I
don't think the communication strategy
might be January might be a couple of
months after
that no workload at the moment we'll be
i' I've been speaking to the comm's team
and they might in might not be January
okay we'll be as flexible as possible
yeah at our earliest opportunity with
our best Endeavors how about
that right I think you got quite quite
lightly on that one Simon um the other
one was the gr opportunities plan uh 23
to2 um it's part of the cabinet page 195
the cabinet papers I've I've had a quick
look at this um
again I've I've got no particular issues
with working with Partners um lots of
these things are quite aspirational is
that the right phrase Mr Perks uh yes
it's
excuse me
it's um the district council's response
to the The Wider leveling up sort of
plan for the County Council and how
we're
um excuse me in tending to discharge our
obligations under the social inclusion
statement which we used to have it's now
morphing into this a growing
opportunities plan so it's very much
continuing that work stream yeah I'm
say there is like I say it's quite quite
generic lots of things that we've we've
talked about before I I think this our
role here would be to see how this pans
out uh and whether there things we it
can be refined as well as we go along so
be um be looking at this to see how
successful is you obviously you as the
title says growing opportunities so I
think this is a a really good report um
working with partners and like say we
can't do all these things on our own um
so yeah I think we know this and uh we
look at uh look at you know particularly
areas of deprivation Etc so it's it's
quite you know is really positive so I'm
happy with this so
um we you know give our give our
approval to this next item on the agenda
is the annual work
program um this is I think it's my
report that will be going to for Council
is this the one just for the oh that's
even better so it's um yeah it's just
our our work program I know we do it I
do a report to for counsil as well
sometime so how was fortunately
correcting me on that one uh again I
think what we're looking at here is is
very reasonable uh We've looked at the
criteria um some of the things that I'd
like to call them standing items whether
is the right phrase you know cabinet
reports performance monitoring I think
it's you know the budget task and finish
group that we're talking about serious
violence Duty hazing associations
antisocial
Behavior public hous his task and finish
crew holding the pr and C commission to
account uh question
time um so lots of things that we talk
about lots of things that are vital uh
things that we've agreed already this
year including the review of the
concessionary parking permits uh and
then because we've got the flexibility
in the program we can then respond to
the changes or or things that are are
emerging so I think that's that's fair
and reasonable um so again any any
comments on that councelor R please yeah
just a quick question
um is this the order of priority I
noticed the paper sum scores sort of
jump a little bit of up and down um is
this our order of
priority or is it just well what is the
order um there's no particular order of
priority no um it's been short of um the
order is just based on things that are
carried over and then new items that
have emerged underneath so sort of
chronologically as they've as as they've
appeared um it's up to the committee and
particularly the chairman but you know
on the committee's advice of what they
want to deal with earlier or later and
obviously other things just depend on
when partners are available so for
instance PCC um when he's available to
come in and that's actually already
booked for March um of this year um this
this uh as in this this cycle basically
um so yeah it's it's open to
discussion thank
you Cat the
please
yeah the topic selection for it that's
just showing
you so that's the form that councils
have been asked to to to complete to
inform the work plan that we've got now
so it's um for for next year yeah feel
free to fill out yeah
yeah or there's nothing to stop you
sorry introducing a new topic halfway
through the year if you wanted to use
that form
yeah
it's on the unscheduled items
on no that's that's the same as I was
just saying regard the PCC and Housing
Association stuff it's led by the County
Council and when they're available to
come um so I'm still in communicating
with them um to get someone to come and
then Tony's going to um you say you're
going to Le that we'll do your own
report and then we'll work out exactly
who needs to come from
County BR much
I do think you sorry you you do need to
start considering your meeting times um
though
because we've now discussed quite a
important cabinet item and sort of a lot
of your committee haven't been able to
stay beyond the end of the meeting
because we're regularly finding that
we've got such an appetite for work that
some quite important issues have being
left to the end so whether we need to
either address the amount of work you're
taking on or the times we make available
for the meeting but and and all the
membership of the committee as well whe
whether people have got the time to do
it or you know
um I I I I don't know where the people
have gone I'm just noting that we
yeah if there's been a lib Dem meeting
scheduled at the end or a time that is
not um conduced to over inuy committee
and with all due respect the um lip Dem
uh group need to uh get them up together
and plan their timetable for group
meetings better than this thank you
there be something I think we have to
have work I may if I may respond there
is no at least unless they've decided to
have a meeting and and not not invited
me there is no lib Dem meeting I am I
have to say a little surprised at The
Exodus I'm aware of one or two things uh
but not uh
not involving all of the group that have
left so I yeah I I can't explain but
there is no sort of uh conspiracy here
yeah no no I I make the point obviously
it's none of my business s of
politically where people are but if we
if we have business set for meetings
that requires the meeting to keep go
until 2:00 we need to sort of be
programming that I think as we go
forward do we just make it on the front
of the meeting then the meeting papers
at the the meeting is scheduled to run
from 10: a until 2 pm make that
intrinsically clear to the members of
this group that that is the running time
for this meeting yeah thank you although
it might finish earli yeah that's fine
that that is the outside edge would you
agree with me on that because it's it's
this is such an important meeting it's
ridiculous to be fair as a new counselor
and a new member of uh this
committee I'm only aware of the
duration from previous meetings yeah I
had you know I I said to my wife because
she's going to pick me up I'm expecting
1:00 based on previous meetings but it's
a long agenda so yeah that would be very
helpful to know yeah what we were
letting ourselves in
for yeah right I think that's I think
that's fair I think yeah sorry caner
very very quick one on item 14 flooding
management which is
um something uh dear to the hearts of a
lot of wet people in
Henley um could you define wet people no
V one that cat the C the right um two
sort of minor points
um I'm I'm surprised the environment
agency is not included um in in in in
the description and surely we need to
look at causes as well as effects when
it comes to
flooding yeah and I think it's cause
effects and the benefits and you know
the the ratio cost benefit ratio Etc
because that comes in my portfol of the
counties it is a complex subject
definitely so but yeah no I'll take take
those points on so I think that's fair
we happy with that annual work
program is seven trend on this anywhere
7 I think when are they due to come in
then so none of those items have been
scheduled yet so once once we've agreed
this annual work program I can start
scheduling things in from
May BR thank you I think we've agreed
that now item number 11 the work plan
again um no changes and again I think
because we've looked at the time of a
available I don't think we can add any
changes at the moment and especially we
got the task and finish groups that
members are going to be spending their
time on so I think hopefully you'll
agree that
one uh urgent business I've got no
urgent
business so I now close the meeting and
thank you for your
attendance thank
you